this is a crazy story there is a
journalist who was investigating Joe
Biden and what happened with Afghanistan
in the pull out the FBI raids his home
and then he disappears quits his job and
is just gone apparently we know some
individuals who actually knew this guy
they reached out no response so maybe
now that the news is broken Rolling
Stones writing about it daily mail is
writing about it maybe he'll pop up and
be like guys you know like someone stole
my car and I went bankrupt my wife left
me that's why I was I was away who knows
but right after he gets raided by the
FBI he just stops cancels his project no
investigation on Joe Biden very
interesting the best part of the story
was when Rolling Stone says this may be
the first time Joe Biden's FBI has rated
a journalist James O'Keefe would like to
have a word with you rolling stone but
uh yeah still a very very crazy story so
we'll talk about that plus oh this one's
my favorite oh man Stacy Abrams coming
out and saying abort the poor that was
just wow okay here's what happens the
Democrats know abortion isn't a winning
midterm issue the economy is so when
Obama comes out and says you gotta talk
about the economy Stacy Abrams Get gets
asked I think it was by Joe Scarborough
and she's like well you know abortions
economic you know women who don't want
kids because they can't afford it well
abortion helps them save money you know
they wouldn't care about the gas prices
if they got rid of that kid and it's
just you know wow Bravo okay abort the
poor in this story you know we we talked
about no fault divorce a week or so ago
and here's my my favorite development
because I didn't catch this one when the
story dropped a week or so like two
weeks ago but they referred to our very
own Ian Crossland as a conservative
commentator I'm very impressed that the
evolution of in your conservative now
it's true
you admitted conservatively liberal all
right all right all right so we'll talk
about all that but before we do my
friends head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and pick up
your ageless multi-collagen from
BioTrust this stuff is fantastic you
need collagen it's a protein it's good
for your joint hair skin nails keeps
your bones nice and strong and makes you
look young and supple maybe you should
go here's some advice go to your
girlfriend and tell her you really need
this and I'm kidding please don't do
that but go to strongerbones in life.com
if you do want to actually be nice and
and get something for your friends or
yourself to help uh stay healthy go to
strongerbonesandlife.com you'll get a 6
day money back guarantee the healthy
aging support of collagen and its ideal
forms five key types of collagens you
need from four different sources
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility to
support maximum benefits and for every
order today BioTrust will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kidhungry.org to date BioTrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
Hungry kids please help BioTrust hit
their goal of 6 million meals this year
it is non-GMO and free of artificial
colors flavors preservatives and
sweeteners free of gluten antibiotics
and rbgh and rbsd nearly no odor or
taste unlike bone broth or other
collagen supplements and there's no
clumping you'll get free shipping with
every order free VIP live health and
fitness coaching from biotrust's Team of
expert nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order and their free
e-report the 14 foods for amazing skin
with every order so again head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com pick up the
collagen if you want to take care of
yourself as you get older but also don't
forget to head over to timcast.com and
become a member to get access to the
exclusive uncensored show Monday through
Thursday at 11 PM you can find that on
our website and uh check out the latest
cast Castle Vlog episode starring rusty
cage and Blair white we we brought them
in and it's deliciously offensive and I
think it's it's good fun and fantastic
but I'm not going to pretend we're doing
like Hollywood quality productions here
guys the actors on this show it's
literally just the crew at the office so
you know quite literally the guy who we
hired to fly a drone is acting and
you're getting what you get but hey
we're working on it you know we got to
get the concept going get better at what
we do and figure it out we're not
Hollywood we want to be better than are
we got to start somewhere if you want to
support our work in building culture go
to timcast.com become a member we got a
new song coming out November 4th you're
not going to want to miss that one's
going to be fantastic and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show be the
notification because YouTube absolutely
is censoring us that's what everybody's
saying it's a it's crazy everybody's
talking about it that's at least that's
what I was told so share the video on
social media joining us today to talk
about this and more is Seth Weathers
good to be here who are you I am a
recovering political political
consultant I spent years running
campaigns I was one of the first people
that Donald Trump hired when he decided
to run for president in 2015 I was nuts
enough to do that and to believe that he
was going to be president
um since then recently I've started a
company freedomspeaksup.com we are in a
conservative Lifestyle brand that we are
trying to our goal is essentially to
tell people be uncensorable and when
people see others out wearing shirts
that have a statement on sometimes it's
funny sometimes it's serious the goal is
to let people know there's other people
that think like you and be unafraid to
speak up so that's what we're trying to
accomplish right on thanks for hanging
out we also got the T-shirt vendor hey
guys I think my lifestyle is more of a
troll Anarchist kind of a Lifestyle
brand when it comes to my t-shirt that
of course I have here and that's why
today I'm wearing my trust the science
shirt on the eve of the CDC just having
another mind-boggling decision for
children today and that's why I'm
wearing a shirt that says trust the
science just like you did with DDT
cigarettes fluoride asbestos glycephate
sugar and I could keep going on and on
and if you are not a trusting peasant
you could get the shirt on the best
politicalshirts.com because you do I am
here thank you so much for having me
well hello everyone your friendly
neighborhood liberal conservative
authoritarian libertarian coming at you
Ian Crossland happy to be here I I think
you know what they wrote Jezebel wrote
that Ian Crossland they're like on Tim
Poole's show conservative commentator
Ian Crossland I'm just like tell me you
don't watch the show without telling me
you don't yeah I'm glad you tweeted it
out because like there's like a hundred
comments of people laughing and he's
just like what in the hell did they even
watch the show it's kind of funny yeah I
I will occasionally take a considerate
conservative Viewpoint for sure because
they're warranted but like you got to be
balanced well we got to read this story
it's going to be fun it's gonna be fun
we also got Serge over here pressing all
the buttons that's right here I am
family at surge.com all right let's jump
into this first story from Rolling Stone
f FBI raids star ABC News producers home
Emmy winning producer James Gordon Meek
had his home rated by the FBI his
colleagues say they haven't seen him
since and this was apparently back in
April look at this at a minute before 5
a.m and April 27th ABC news's James
Gordon Meek fired off a tweet with a
single word facts the Network's National
Security investigative producer was
responding to a former CIA agent Mark
how do you say his polymeropolis
take that the Ukrainian military with
assistance from the U.S was thriving
against Russian forces Paulie miropolis
tweet filled with acronyms And
indecipherable indecipherable Delay
person like itp's UW and Ew with itself
a missive from The Washington Post
Pentagon reporter Dan Le Mans blah blah
blah blah okay really what the story
comes down to
is I think we have this tweet here
let's just go through the the quick
bullet points on this one outside ABC
news's James Gordon Meek's Apartment A
surreal scene was unfolding and his
storied career is about to come crashing
down multiple sources for me with the
matter say the emmy-winning producer was
the target of an FBI raid none of his
neighbors with whom Rolling Stone spoke
with have seen him since his neighbors
haven't even seen him an ABC
representative tells Rolling Stone he
resigned very abruptly and hasn't worked
for us for months
it's unclear what story if any would
have put Meek in the FBI's crosshairs
well not necessarily it's been reported
by several outlets he was investigating
Biden's withdrawal from Afghanistan and
then abruptly vanished now here's the
best part of the story
Rolling Stone says Meek has been charged
with no crime but independent observers
believe the raid is among the first and
quite possibly the first to be carried
out on a journalist by the Biden
Administration okay well uh I would just
like to point out James O'Keefe does
exist he was also rated by the FBI but
uh here's the story man this is a
troubling Trend now I don't know what
happened to this guy okay the report was
that he was investigating Afghanistan
very very bad day for Biden and I'll and
I'll remind you when you look at the
aggregate polling that's when Joe Biden
went underwater his approval rating was
a was was higher than his disapproval
Afghanistan happened he flipped the
Democrats right now they're desperately
trying to reverse that narrative and win
back support but the economy is just
it's beating them down then you get a
guy who's working on this big story gone
well Rolling Stones is also reporting
right now that he might have had
classified information and that's why
the FBI rated him but we have to
understand that that what What's
Happening Here is not out of the
playbook out of the democratic party
when Joe Biden was was vice president
the Obama Administration terrified
newsrooms just like they did weddings
and hospitals all throughout the Middle
East with their drone strikes and Obama
used the Espionage Act more than any
other president before him to
specifically put a record number of
journalists and their sources in jail so
we have to understand here this is the
continuation of the Obama doj FBI that
prosecutes people that wanted to do real
journalism they went after James O'Keefe
they probably went after this guy we
don't know all the details here but he
quit his job he he didn't publish his
book and he disappeared people can't
find him of course people are
automatically some people are going to
go off and say oh maybe they Michael
Hastings him uh which is another
journalist that also died under the
Obama Administration also had allegedly
classified information during the Obama
admination while investigating who's he
investigating he was investigating a top
General that was uh you know that that
he was going to expose and he came out
and said hey you know he tried to use
his neighbor's car he said they had
people following him so so again what
the Democrats are possible what they
could possibly do is unspeakable with
what they already did with the Obama
Administration okay what we know from
the Obama Administration is that more
journalists and whistleblowers were
charged with the under the Espionage Act
and other charges then all of the
president's presidents combined what we
know about Michael Hastings is that who
was he was it was it Hayden you want to
Google this wasn't Hayden it was another
uh topic he was investigating some top
General guy and then one day he shows up
to his neighbor's house saying he needs
to borrow their car or something about
he saw someone under his car tampering
with it the next thing we hear John
Brennan Brennan CI director John Brennan
the next thing we hear is that he was
speeding down Wilshire Boulevard
uncontrollably and slammed into a tree
and his car burst into flames like two
in the morning yeah so the one people
were like maybe he was drunk and he just
depressed and suicidal and just hit the
gas and just didn't let go other people
were like maybe they watched he went to
his neighbors and said my car was
can I use your card please because
someone was messing with my car it's not
the same no you never said no do you
guys remember when uh Sheamus Freedom
tunes that he produced a debunking
left-wing uh memes video and there's
this researcher who made the pyramid
it's the reverse pyramid of conspiracy
theories have you seen this I don't
think I've seen that one there's a so
this this pyramid shows like on the
bottom it's conspiracy theories that are
true and it's like you know MK Ultra it
happened we know the documents are
completely classified and then at the
top it's like anti-semitic point of no
return and the funny thing is it says
something like Epstein is true at the
bottom and then it says powerful uh
individuals trafficking children is
considered a conspiracy theory and it's
like bro that's the same thing like the
Epstein thing that's what it is Elaine
Maxwell's in prison for trafficking
miners it's not a conspiracy theory
anymore she's been convicted now you
know who was it I'd love to see that
list but here's the funny thing like
after something like that happens one of
my favorite stories is Chris I think it
was Chris Reagan tweeting that when
Epstein dies he gets into an Uber and
the Uber driver turns around immediately
and says yo that guy didn't kill himself
I like that's the that was the cultural
shock when that story dropped so when
you hear that a national security
reporter here's the story from the daily
message out ABC national security
producer hasn't been seen since April
when FBI mysteriously raided his house
journalist was writing a book about
Biden's disastrous withdrawal withdrawal
from Afghanistan he abruptly quits tells
the guy he's working the book with I'm
out you know I don't have anything to do
with this and now no one his neighbors
haven't seen him his colleagues haven't
heard from him we actually someone we
work with I'm going to keep the details
you know vague because we're trying to
investigate this tried reaching out
because they know him and they're like
yo he's not responding so uh I don't
know but let me just tell you the
conspiracy theorists scored a whole
bunch of points over the past couple of
years we are well past the point where
we just dismiss these things as
far-fetched a journalist was rated by
the FBI and went missing James O'Keefe
was raided by the FBI his Saving Grace
is that he's famous and people got their
eye on him but I wouldn't be surprised
if something really crazy happened here
I'm just realizing that this was in
April so has has there been research to
note like what's his family say like
where is he like I mean it's the guy
like truly missing from family friends
everyone I mean his neighbors haven't
seen him the same like apparently they
reached out to him so that's that that's
why we're here talking about it yeah I'd
like to know what his family has to say
or who they are family yeah
don't know you would think if he was
married or had kids that they would have
been at least vocal about it and if
they're not vocal about it then they're
in on it or they're scared right yeah
meaning that they're in on it like they
know something well look I mean when the
FBI shows up at your door breaks it down
and points a gun at your family member's
head I mean that's a message right there
and when you do that to journalists when
you do that to people that that
whistleblower when you do that when
people try to get accurate truthful
information to the general public you're
not on the good side here I mean I think
it's pretty clear and obvious we used to
have journalists we used to have
whistleblowers we used to have things
like you know Watergate we used to have
uh there's another you know comment here
that's an adult comment linked to of
course a whistleblower that goes deep a
part of someone's jugular
those situations those scenarios those
individuals can exist under this
Administration mainly because of just
how brutal they are towards journalism
it's like Tim you mentioned that maybe
he had classified information that I
think Luke mentioned that Rolling Stone
is is reporting that that there's a
potential that he had classified
information and was going to probably uh
blow the whistle on on something even
more nefarious to already a very
nefarious nasty story and another thing
that kind of boggles my mind is you know
why are journalists puppeteering why are
they cheerleading this Administration
that is literally punishing them that is
spreading fear in The Newsroom that is
terrifying them from even doing their
job I I don't understand it uh I do on
some levels but the general public
should be asking some serious questions
what's that that phenomenon where slaves
will start to love their slave master
Stockholm Stockholm syndrome it's like
journalists are in a state of such shock
and Terror that they're being the the
the government's spying on their their
like I don't think most journalists are
afraid of this government I think
they're a little too cozy yeah yeah it's
it's well I mean no no no I I
I think technically Ian's right
journalists are in a state of fear the
people you're referring to Seth aren't
journalists they're you know government
shills they're masquerading as
journalists so the people who are actual
journalists this is what happens to them
yeah you get raided by the FBI I mean
look at James O'Keefe the FBI raided his
house the whole thing is is is nonsense
and then the Rolling Stone has the nerve
to be like this could be the first time
it's like bro
first what is that either or possibly
the first time when people point out
James O'Keefe got rated the response
from all of these people on Twitter is
he's not a journalist
no he is a journalist James he's a
journalist and he has news organizations
defending him these people don't like
him personally so they say he's not a
journalist but it's like just because
you don't like the things he writes the
same thing is true of Alex Jones guess
what surprise surprise Alex Jones is a
journalist oh no now they're all Angry
saying don't you dare conflate the work
we do with Alex Jones if you break down
what they are legally doing and their
protections yeah Alex Jones is a
journalist sorry that's just a reality
but I gotta tell you this when you get
these corporate chill quote unquote
journalists that make fake news up and
claim things like Ian Crossland as a
conservative and then have the nerve to
insult Alex Jones oh hi a ROM if I say I
find it laughable
shout out to Jezebel for writing that
bizarre article by the way
conservative commentator interesting
Society where people appreciate the
government's class of ability to
classify documents if they didn't have
that ability we'd have been overrun and
conquered because we would have lost
Wars like World War II you need secrecy
but at the same time we also glorify
journalists that like expose the the
corruption within the government by you
know it maybe not receiving classified
documents but I don't know how they like
Julian Assange for instance who he
received like those that was a
classified video the uh what is a
collateral murder where it shows the
soldiers like just from a helicopter
like gunning people down in civilians
gutting civilians down look what they do
to Assange yes and so we've got both
dichotomies like there's Heroes on you
know you could and they're at odds but
they're both on our side I just very
strange I think the US government is
full of criminals and corrupt
Psychopaths and then you have people
like Julian Assange who are like I'm
going to expose evil people right
technically he's a criminal like he got
classified information and revealed no
that was not a criminal at all yeah it
is actually he's protected by the First
Amendment and he's not even American to
receive and disperse classified
information you're allowed to do that
the New York Times does it every day
yeah there's whistleblower laws that
protect individuals that come forward
and say hey there was some wrongdoing in
our government many people tried to go
through the official Avenues and and
they of course were told to shut up you
just can't have stolen the documents
himself but if they're provided to him
he has the ability again like he said
that's what journalism they do that all
the time but like even if he knows
they're stolen yes yes I can't commit
the crime but if someone else does it
for me then I'm not in the clear it
doesn't adore you if they didn't direct
them to yeah right right you can't you
you can't be if you're a journalist and
someone comes to you and says I have a
diary you can be okay I'll take it yeah
yeah well they look at Trump's tax
records uh what's her name put uh put
them on the show yes I forgotten
together how quick
but yeah she put him on her show and was
heralded for it yeah they were cheering
I mean this is really funny there's um
some some leftist organization filmed
some Republican Congressman or something
under undercover pretending to be a
trump supporter saying we need pardons
for the January 6th defendants and he's
like well we got to win the White House
first and they're all like oh we gotta
we got him and it's just like and how is
what James O'Keefe does not journalism
like you do this the same thing and then
claim Veritas is you get that is
partisan BS you know what we need I I
would say probably the only real news
organization in the country right now
okay that's not fair but the most
prominent National level is Veritas yeah
and I say it's not fair I wouldn't call
any of the local news outlets news
organizations I wouldn't call uh e
colonies let's go media local media
disbursement the New York Times police
propaganda narrative garbage the the
there's a new album that came out
semaphore and it's Ben Smith formerly of
BuzzFeed in the New York Times along
with a bunch of other people who I I
think are just terrible but they're
doing reporting now and they've done
some interviews that are actually quite
good and one of them
is this guy this opinion editor from The
New York Times who got fired for
publishing Tom Cotton's op-ed calling
for the military to uh you know stop the
riots and he's basically like they're
trying to Panda to progressives they had
an opportunity to speak out to call it
out and say we're not here to Pander to
you but they chose we're going to be
Mother Jones on steroids or whatever
that's the New York Times it's not news
it's not investigative Journal there's
like when you talk about journalism you
talk about there's reporting where
people are like hey I got a piece of
paper I'm going to read it to you and
report on what I saw then there's people
that investigate investigative
journalists are like here's a piece of
paper I got to figure out where it came
from who wrote it and they'll do all
this work behind the scenes to figure
stuff out that's project Veritas they're
investigators now New York Times Kylie
Chung from Jezebel who wrote this weird
article about me calling me conservative
misquoting me is not an investigative
journalist she's maybe you could call
her journalist because she wrote in a
journal that's now online but you know
let's we're gonna walk our way to that
story because first we got to talk about
this one from timgas.com Georgia
gubernatorial candidate Stacey Abram
says abort version can help address
inflation issues why that's right if
you're concerned about the rising costs
for your household consider killing your
unborn child that's the news apparently
so uh you know she said you can't
divorce being forced to care in unwanted
pregnancy from the economic realities of
having a child Abrams continued adding
that we don't have the luxury of
reducing it or separating them out
Abrams avoided offering policy solutions
to counter-inflation instead saying that
a governor can address housing prices a
governor can address the cost of
Education blah blah blah okay so here's
the point we used to have um
institutions in this country to make
sure that if a woman got pregnant that
there was a means and resources made
available to her and that was called
marriage that uh we had shotgun weddings
you guys know about that right dude
would get a girl pregnant the dad would
go you're marrying my daughter and
that's a that's a Trope it's a meme but
once they break down that institution
you now have women who are like Oh no I
got pregnant and the guy has abandoned
me okay they're supposed to be child
support laws and payments for a reason
Stacey Abrams could offer up I don't
know that instead she's like women are
concerned about the cost of goods
because they're about to have a baby has
she considered that perhaps the reason
some women might not want the pregnancy
is that they fear not being able to
afford it and so the issue isn't that
they should abort the baby they may
actually really want the kid
that's how insane and nightmarish this
is so how about we abort inflation that
might be a good start if it's a
financial concern yeah we can get rid of
that maybe we can uh deal with
fractional Reserve banking policies
quantitative easing the Federal Reserve
yeah how about you just stop printing
money out of thin air giving it to the
biggest companies on Wall Street how
about you just stop spending money
willy-nilly on stupid projects and then
maybe you know people could afford
having children and you don't have to
abort them which is absolutely crazy
Seth you're from Georgia uh you got to
get in this get it yeah come on this is
not the reasons right now okay this is
this is an embarrassment you're putting
it on the national stage for me right
now
um yeah it's it's Stacy Abrams is a mess
but fortunately based on what I'm seeing
on the ground there she's not going to
win this race
um she's going to go directly from this
gubernatorial race to she will be
running for president shortly after it
probably I think she actually tries in
2024. I really do think she finds a way
into that because who knows what happens
with Biden I I I wouldn't disagree they
don't have anybody I mean in fact what
was the latest polling like only 24
people 24 of people only 24 people I
believe in now only 24 of people said
they would vote for him at this point
there was a couple polls one said 33 of
people would vote for him so they they
need anybody they can get you got Buddha
judge but he uh talks like this uh and
you're like come on
I'm sorry he doesn't have the Charisma I
know and Stacy just mimics him she's an
election denial you know this is true
she's an election tonight I I can't
support an election denier you know so I
I watched the media talk about election
nighters all day and night and then I
saw this viral video of Stacey Abrams
then I saw another viral video like oh
man she's dangerous for society that's
right it's very dangerous to democracy
yes that she denies election what
election did Stacy deny she denied I
think she may have denied 2016. 2018. no
no to 2016. that Hillary Clinton and oh
man but she denied her own loss right
that's for governor in Georgia before
before she even got to denying that she
lost and refusing to accept the results
of her own election I think she may have
been a 2016 denier as well did you say
she lost her 2018 election then claimed
that it was what rigged she claimed oh
yeah she claimed there was fraud and
manipulation voter suppression well well
yeah we had the highest of black voter
suppression specifically in the election
year she ran we had the highest black
turnout in Georgia history but it was is
the same year that voter suppression
kept her from winning I mean even right
now voter turnout in Georgia is higher
than what it was yeah it's through the
roof yes yeah 73 higher at this point in
the election than 2018. that's
incredible that's nice and they're
higher than in and they're all voting
Camp huh
well I don't know about all of them but
I do think that Kemp wins and I think he
wins by a decent margin I think we're in
the seven to ten range what Legend to so
many people voting
in this election more than ever do you
think do you think there's a lot of
efforts to to try to get people to vote
do you think it's mail-in ballots do you
think it's maybe people moving down to
Georgia uh no I I think obviously
there's a lot of efforts all over trying
to get people to turn out and vote but I
think right now you're seeing people
that normally were not paying attention
I'm seeing this personally just from you
know friend groups Etc uh but people
that weren't necessarily paying
attention like what the hell there's a
lot happening here and I don't like it
and I think you're seeing people turn up
and people that were not so political
before they're maybe not speaking out
about it a lot because they're kind of
afraid of backlash but they're getting
out to vote and I think that we're going
to see I think we're if the polls are
tightening as we get closer to the race
and Republican favor
which tends to typically happen I think
we're going to see actually a I think
we're gonna have a pretty big Republican
Victory oh the the real clear politics
national average in the generic ballot
jumped by like two points today so I'm
doing I'm doing a segment and I grab the
RCP average and it was 2.8 and I was
like oh look they jumped one point and
then I'm like so I start recording 15
minutes in when I load Real Clear
Politics it it refreshes and now it's at
3.1 and I was like whoa yeah it jumped
even more in the time that I started
talking about it so the national
aggregate poll yeah so so it's it's uh
the generic ballot aggregate so all
these different polls ask people if you
were going to vote in the midterms would
it be a Republican or a Democrat they're
these are not uh the swing District
polls yeah they're asking aoc's District
who are you going to vote for so when
you see at the national level a three or
four point swing for Republicans this is
significant yeah I think Georgia at
minimum we will pick up one
congressional seat in an already Red
State so and one out of you know out of
15 congressional seats that's pretty
significant I gotta imagine that Biden's
almost refusal to talk about inflation
is like gotta be driving people insane
because it's it's obvious with gas
prices going up food prices going up
that there's a big inflation issue right
now and like Biden whenever he's asked
about it what I see he just kind of acts
like it's not not that big of a deal
it's like oh it's a global thing it's
not but like duh but also the America is
the leading global economy so it's an
American thing the global economy is an
American thing well by Design Saudi
Arabia to join bricks yeah you know this
has been circulating around for a little
bit
that's the end of the Petro dollar and
when that happens America is in for a
very very they're going to do a currency
recall probably get rid of the US dollar
do a U.S Central Bank currency and
crypto Go full crypto tax everybody get
people's people's dollars will be worth
a hundredth of what they were worth but
that that's not that's not necessarily
relevant to what's going to happen first
what's gonna happen first is you are not
going to be able to buy anything because
we don't make anything clothing oh it's
going to be brutal it's going to be like
hey I need to buy a shirt here's it's 50
bucks you're gonna go for a white
T-shirt that's right because stitch up
your old t-shirts stitch up your old
socks as someone that sells a lot of
shirts there's actually a lot of trouble
getting a hold of just the blank shirts
even print on right now especially
certain sizes like after covid hit and
everything it became a real issue you
know just trying to build blanks the
United States manufactures very little
we outsourced all these other countries
and we get away with it because the US
dollar is the settlement layer for the
world the Petro dollar the reserve
currency so people are like I need US
dollars to do to do trade deals with
other countries you take a look at what
happened to Gaddafi he wants trade in
Gold he's gone you'll get Saddam Hussein
oh started trading with Euro he's gone
but now the U.S can't keep it up and
they try to that's what they do with the
Middle East the war everything they do
is a desperate attempt to maintain This
Global dominance now it's Saudi Arabia
flipping off Joe Biden and boy are they
panicking over this prices are going up
and they can't do anything about it
Saudi Arabia joins brics that's it US
dollars out there Brooks is already
saying you know we can use the rupee and
we can use the ruble we can use the one
we don't need US dollars for for
settlements anymore bye-bye in the
United States this means you're going to
want to buy a computer that computer is
made in Southeast Asia they're going to
say we don't want US Dollars you don't
make anything what do we need your
dollars for we're going to buy from you
not right now it's oil right now they'll
say yeah we need US dollars because we
want to buy oil once we lose this to
Bricks they're going to go you got corn
I guess I guess we could buy coffee we
got food wheat and corn you think that
part of the reason why they're telling
farmers in Europe to stop farming is
because they're trying to set up a
system where now people buy food from
America maybe maybe maybe they had a
meeting where they're like guys we're
going to lose the petrodollar what do we
do uh what do we export the most corn
and corn syrup okay tell our allies to
stop making food
all right I guess if we don't have the
Petro dollar we can withhold food but we
don't have fertilizer either comes from
Russia so true good luck
and I mean I suppose Ukraine as well I
don't know man it seems intentionally
they're gonna starve people out but it's
gonna be fun the people who have Farms
live in the middle of nowhere who've
been homesteading they're gonna go what
happened and the people who live in
cities are going to turn into like
ravenous ghouls running around eating
each other I don't know what the media
like CNN and MSNBC have been framing
Biden as when they talked about
inflation or if they even talk to them
about inflation on those channels well
for there's the clips I see of them he's
just like kind of space cadet on that
stuff probably by intention I don't I
think he's intentionally not addressing
it I don't think Biden's intentionally
saying or doing anything he's pretty far
out of it
yeah I mean better calf care next no
wrestling Trinity pressure yeah I don't
think there's a lot of intentions I
haven't heard a mention the Federal
Reserve once the Federal Reserve is the
issue like that there's this private
company printing our money away
Wicked yep
yeah I wonder if uh you guys remember
Zeitgeist yeah the movie you seen that
one yeah so that thing I've actually
seen it it's worth watching people I
missed a lot so this is you know like
the early internet era of conspiracy
theory videos going around and uh you
had like loose change you had Zeitgeist
and in it it talks about false flags and
stuff but I wonder if was it part one
that talks about fractional Reserve
banking probably it was they did like
Jesus and like the the history of
religion then they did Federal Reserve
fractional what was the third one they
had like a three I think it was
conspiracy yeah
yeah so uh they talk about fractional
Reserve I feel like that kind of
documentary going viral or in the early
days of the internet had a huge impact
on a lot of people leads a lot of people
to to uh politicians like Ron Paul and
now all of a sudden you have a culture
that outright understands fractional
Reserve banking enough to reject it
understands the FED enough to reject it
and these people aren't going away you
know like we're gonna have these
conversations all day every day and they
would love it the machine the fed the
establishment the unit party they would
love it if we stopped talking about how
they manipulate the system and steal
money from you not only are they not
going away they took us off fractional
Reserve Banking and now we're on a no
Reserve banking system where they can
print infinite amounts they don't even
need 90 or 9 10 in the bank to loan out
99 cents on the 10. I gotta wonder if
what that means is they know the
system's about to implode and they're
extracting as much as possible in a
currency recall and then everybody's
gonna lose
the U.S look if the U.S loses this the
brics Nations OPEC plus they're going to
be laughing all the way to the bank
because it they can do sure maybe
they'll do a currency recall but it's
pointless the US dollar is going to hit
hyperinflation we don't make anything so
let me just simplify it
we go to Korea and say we want a bunch
of laptops and they say what are you
going to give for us or like what are
you going to give us for it and then we
say we will give you dollars and they go
what can I do with that you can buy from
us and what can I buy from you corn yeah
so they're going to say no thanks the
computers are worth more than the corn
you have to offer and they're going to
go to China and say we need the rare
earth minerals and China's gonna be like
deal they're going to go to Russia and
OPEC and they're saying we need oil and
they're going to say deal and the us is
going to be like but we shut down
Keystone Pipeline and we we stopped
energy production so we don't make
energy we don't make uh raw materials
here anymore we don't Harvest them we do
a whole lot of nothing I mean look we do
some of that stuff in the US but it's
way down Trump was trying to bring back
manufacturing and that's probably why
you can see what's happening but I hope
you guys are ready for a big ride it's
gonna be fun yeah Biden is a horrible
Diplomat people don't like him he's mean
um he he was a terrible military
commander he he we he surrendered our
military Terry to the Taliban in
Afghanistan and people see the weakness
in the idiocy and like the old Frailty
and they just don't take them seriously
I don't that's the vibe I'm getting
Saudi Arabians are like you know if
there's anyone we're ever going to cut
ties with in the United States it's Joe
Biden that guy's a dick it's not
personality it's the policies it's it's
what they're what he's doing that's
pushing forward we I could get in a
whole rant about Saudi Arabia let's
let's jump to this next story because
that's what I was trying to get to
conservatives are coming for no fault
divorce from Jezebel they say after the
fall of Roe right-wing media have been
ratcheting up their rhetoric against no
fault divorce expect policy to follow
the reason why this story is from August
we're talking about now I didn't catch
this when it came out but they refer to
our good friend Ian Crossland as a
conservative commentator so let me show
you first a little bit what they say in
the beginning I love this because they
talk about us where where are they going
to do it
an authoritarian liberal yeah you were
right about that yeah
they mention uh here we go in it uh
there's a popular conservative
influencer Tim Poole oh really I'm
conservative now in a segment on the
show I love that one because they say it
a lot but conservatives are like yeah
Temple is not conservative temple in a
segment on his show was Delight that was
delightfully titled no fault divorce has
destroyed men's confidence and marriage
men don't want to get married anymore
yeah that's true there are studies that
show that we're not just like screaming
into the wind we're like reading things
and going wow look at that according to
pool you know guys can't you at least
cite the thing I'm reading and not me
I'm not like fabricating things on the
wall they say we have no fault divorce
laws to blame for the rise of prenuptial
agreements
yes duh okay moving on which allegedly
plays men at risk of being robbed by
gold digging thieving Jezebels oh name
drop their own website willfully
ignoring how the court system is a long
history of re-traumatizing and
destroying the lives of rape and
domestic violence victims no we know
full well that's called fault right when
a guy commits a crime against his wife
now there's fault you can get a divorce
congratulations you understand what no
fault means
the best part of the article they write
in the same episode on Poole's show
conservative commentator Ian Crossland
adds quote we live in this culture where
no fault divorce is the law of the land
dot dot dot if young folks know they're
in an environment where divorce is not
an option I firmly believe they're going
to be more careful about who they choose
to marry also a very dry fact statement
I mean it's a dry analysis Ian didn't
come out and say arrest all of the women
who try to get divorces he said if
people can't divorce they're probably
more careful about it yeah but I didn't
say that if I did that was a misspeak I
said that if people can't get a uh no
fault divorce if people can't divorce
wait what does it say if uh if young
first of all I don't use the word folks
that's the Obama speak and I know I
don't use that word so they're
misquoting me they took it
we got to pull that up because I don't
they didn't link to the story either so
I don't know what the referencing
something like two months ago but it
wasn't that if people can't get a
divorce it's if people can't get at no
fault divorce then they're going to be
much more choosy about getting marriage
I don't I don't ever advocate for people
not being able to get divorced that's
complete Insanity if a guy beats his
wife she should leave him and make him
pay yeah
so they actually did link to the segment
and it was with uh oh Dr Chloe
Carmichael was on the show at the time
this from a few months ago I'm not gonna
play through it and try and find the
point where where Ian says the word
folks or whatever but I just love that
this is how the media operates they just
they lie they they falsely frame things
yeah I might I might have used those
words but referencing that if they can't
easily get a divorce so I'm not saying
that they're misquoting me I'd have to
reference the data here's here's the
point I want to make thank you uh
Jezebel for giving us the opportunity to
bring this subject back up if no fault
divorce is the law
then marriage does not exist
dude you can marry a woman and she can
leave you the next day and take half
your money literally well that's a bit
extreme but she can't typically they
would annul not divorce what's the
difference annulment means it didn't
happen so if you get married to someone
and the next day try to dissolve the
marriage they would probably file an
annulment and not allow a divorce
divorce but but there are circumstances
where it could be like six months to a
year and all of a sudden now it's like
they are entitled to half of your
belongings so marriage is a contract you
know between two people the state
certifies it to enforce the contract and
it used to be in the past someone would
be like I don't I don't like her she's
annoying and I want to be with her I'm
like yeah well too bad you s you entered
into a contract with this person you
have to now abide by this so they create
no fault divorce and now it's basically
dating
it's like okay there's no marriage
anymore it used to be that you would
date you would not there'd be no binding
contract or anything and if you didn't
like it you'd walk away
then you'd say you know what I think
this is working I'm willing to enter
into a lifetime contract with you
enforced by the law and they'd say okay
and you do it no fault divorce means
marriage doesn't exist anymore for all
intents and purposes except for the
purpose of stealing money from you know
one one party or the other yeah it's an
opt-in business contract where you split
your finances but the fact that one of
the partners can cancel the contract and
then take half of your wealth is
complete Insanity Luke if me and you
started a company with me so it is like
doesn't mean you started a company it
made a million dollars and is that what
the young kids are calling it yeah well
you know we'll just call it you want to
start a company Luke will you start a
company with me
and then if you decided to leave the
company I mean what do you I think you
don't get any the company still stands
and I have the rest I still own he would
own it I mean and this a better argument
would be I entered to a contract with
Luke that I'll provide lumber for him in
exchange for uh coal and then one day
Luke delivers coal and then I say I'm
I'm terminating the contract and then
looks like what you can't do that where
you're supposed to give me the lumber no
I had no fault contract is call sex is
that what the roof
no I'm just saying like in a marriage
you're basically saying we're going to
build a life together whatever that may
mean I mean maybe the wife works maybe
the husband works maybe they both work
but the reason why the assets are pulled
together is that they're forming a
family unit they're gonna have kids and
this is going to help a woman who gets
pregnant and things like that no fault
divorce means that you can enter into a
contract share all your resources and
then someone can leave so perhaps a
better way to explain it is you know you
merge companies and it's like you let's
say you have a podcasting company and a
major media conglomerate worth tens of
billions of dollars says we're going to
do a merger with you and then you go
okay but it's a no fault merger I can
leave and take half half of Warner
Brothers like that's so weird and then
you can also have kids with them get
married to a woman have kids and then
she can just be like one day be like man
I did some Ayahuasca I had a change of
heart I'm Gonna Leave You take the kid
and make you pay me money yep you're
like what in the hell is going on what
how is this even like a romantic or like
righteous thing there's no marriage
there there's no marriage there at this
point with no fault divorce marriage is
basically a tax bracket that's it it's
like oh we're married now so we get a
tax benefit but anyone can leave at any
time so there's no real contract there's
no point in doing it what's the purpose
only that you can give your spouse money
untaxed that's it it's just a business
basically a loophole almost at this
point well child custody is where a lot
comes into all these things of course as
well and then that unfortunately becomes
in a lot of cases The Leverage that's
used in the divorce unfortunately that
that becomes as much of more leverage
and oftentimes than even the money
like who gets the kid yeah and how would
that work like a a person would say you
can have the house if I can have the kid
kind of thing
or vice versa I don't think that that's
what they would say in court but it's
like a bargaining chip like the yes kids
being used as a bargaining chip and
divorce has been going on probably since
the beginning of divorce but but it used
to be that if you try to get a divorce a
court would be like no
it's like I want to get a divorce
because you know he uh I mean they were
there were serious cases where women
were being abused but they couldn't
prove it and the courts would be like no
divorce nice trial you can't do it
that's a problem the solution isn't no
fault divorce that's insane
because now you now you're going to get
fatherlessness women who are getting
abortions because they can't afford the
kids instead of having a father who's
around with the fatherlessness
fatherlessness needs leads to crime and
poverty and now we're seeing the ripple
effect of this where politicians like
Stacey Abrams are like the solution to
women who can't afford a kid is to kill
the kid and that's insane the solution
used to be someone had to earn to
provide for that kid now it's just like
well that's not going to happen so just
kill it with fault divorce before what
1969 or whenever it got introduced and
it was like the Bolsheviks actually the
Russian Bolsheviks are the ones who kind
of created the idea of that you could
just divorce with no fault um but before
that was it that a guy would beat his
wife and she couldn't prove it so she
couldn't leave him kind of thing and
that was a problem so they were like we
got to liberate these women I don't know
if that was the main reason why they
decided to enact no fault divorce but
they're often you'd go to court and be
like we want to get a divorce and the
judge would be like nope I you know
sentence you to marriage counseling
so they would not divorce and then the
argument was that women were being
beaten raped and traumatized and it led
to suicides and no fault divorce
resulted in a lowering of the suicide
rate among many married women
yeah
don't get married that's the crazy thing
it's like you have a problem with
marriage don't get married but they do
and then they're like hey it's not
working out for me let's destroy the
institution instead of just realizing we
made a mistake like I don't want to tell
you don't get married if you want to get
married get married but I don't want to
get married right now because of no
fault divorce
straight up I mean I'm just being honest
I don't want to get married and then
have the woman just be like yeah you're
acting like a jerk I'm out give me half
of your everything you've ever earned
I'm like what are you kidding me no way
yeah and fortunately I'm with a woman
that feels the same way and I think
there are a lot of people out there
Russell Brand was married to Katy Perry
right yeah I think the story was that
when they got divorced he was entitled
to a ton of money and he was like I
don't want it yeah and I mean like
Russell Brand is already rich so he's
like I don't want to deal with I don't
care about that yeah but I still respect
that
for sure but I mean you see this is the
problem when you have guys who are like
you know what I'm a man and I have money
so I don't need to take half of your
stuff meanwhile you look at every other
case the overall majority it's the woman
being like I get your stuff this is true
look at Mackenzie Bezos amazing she got
what did she she got half right I think
she get half of it wasn't 50 billion or
something that's crazy I got married and
they got divorced oh yeah yeah she has a
four second time she married some guy
yeah did the guy take half of her 50
billion when they got divorced is that
record I don't know if he took there's
no way yeah because because that we
weren't married long enough yeah and it
was after the finances had been gained
she was married to Bezos prior while he
was building the wealth yeah but with a
marriage you get if they divorce don't
you get all the money back to birth like
everything you've ever been worth if you
were from yeah but but it's not so
unless you sign a screen up you had
assets coming into a marriage and so
those get taken to it into account as
well and States it also varies state by
state you know what the rules are when
it comes to that also it can be
everything you've ever earned and owned
like if you own a house and then you get
married and then a couple years later
you get divorced yeah you're out that's
the funniest thing the Trope about
divorce is the husband always gets
booted from the house and then I watched
breaking bad and I was like oh there you
go you know because I'm breaking bad
she's like get out you're like no it's
my house and the cops were like it's his
house have a nice day and she was like
oh no but that it's crazy that these are
the tropes that you know you watch The
Simpsons and the the van houtens or
whatever get divorced and the and the
you know Mouse's dad just leaves and he
goes and lives in like a bachelor pad
and I'm like why it's his house you know
all of these things like
it's just you grow up watching that
stuff and you're like what's the point
of marriage I gotta tell you man
feminism seems to have been one of the
worst possible things for women in not
in the terms of like you know they got
their independence they get their jobs
and here's this one's for you Young
Turks and feminist websites you can take
this one because I know you're going to
want to spin this one out of context but
uh the issue is now guys can bang
whoever they want whenever they want
with no strings attached that's a not a
benefit to women no when when regardless
of what your mentality is let's just
break it down to simple probabilities
and numbers
women when they get pregnant they either
have to have an abortion to get rid of
it or they have to have a child whereas
if a guy goes to a party and there's a
bunch of you know people doing crazy
stuff and he hooks up with a random
chick because we're in this hookup
culture and she doesn't know who he is
and she gets pregnant dude has nothing
to worry about that's a problem the
problem for is for the woman the benefit
is for the men guys can go and party and
hook up and never have to think twice
about it but women do so I don't know
how this hookup culture benefited women
I guess but there was an article in the
New York Post today that was titled I'm
dating so many men I need an Excel
spreadsheet to organize my love life and
reading that that story kind of was was
a little depressing uh understanding our
our current landscape but this is where
we're at you know and I I think we have
to you know talk about these things uh
from from an open-minded way you know
different people have their different
experiences they need to go through them
in order to see that they were wrong but
I think also as a society we should be
considering the long-term kind of
consequences for them and having those
kind of conversations and debates whoa
this is big someone just superintended
us right now Ian was right about folks
Jezebel misquoted Sheamus as Ian the
timestamp is
10303 really can we uh 103 oh we only
have the clip I don't have the the full
episode so I don't know where that would
act that would actually be in the
episode but it was Sheamus who said it
and they claimed it was Ian who said it
that is
that is interesting is that illegal for
them to do that it's not illegal it's a
civil tort meaning uh oh it's the clips
are actually broken down arranged
marriage loans I miss that guy by the
way I love you Seamus where are you at
uh it means if you so that's a false
statement effect that's that's actually
serious on Jezebel's part it's been up
for months we've now discovered that the
question now is Damages okay damages is
girl that you wrote it come on the show
Kylie Chong that's not talk to me about
this that's not how it works
have you lost money or have you been
damaged by them attributing Sheamus to
you
I mean people are making fun of you you
need corrective marketing now and that's
I I understand the process no but this
honestly I'd rather just communicate
with Kylie about it all right well in
public corrective marketing we may have
to do for the show and I mean this so
when it comes to defamation damages in
the form of corrective marketing means
if if you know one of the aspects of
this show is we have you in here for a
reason Ian is not your typical
conservative commentator quite the
opposite and we don't actually know what
your background is you're kind of a
weird dude and that works some people
don't like you some people really like
you some people say you were one some
people say you roll 20s well that's kind
of the point we don't want to make a
cookie cutter show so having opinions
that we can't predict or having weird
arguments sometimes makes it more
interesting than your average
one-of-the-mill show if they're now
lying to people and saying that Ian is a
conservative commentator it is actually
hurting the point of having you on the
show that means we have to do corrective
marketing I gotta buy a Times Square
billboard a view that's really expensive
it's gonna cost Jezebel and and
Jezebel's gonna have to have to pay for
that because they're claiming you're a
conservative when the point I mean
Luke's not a concern conservative Luke
said and Anarchist libertarian type I'm
weird middle of the road Ian is weird
all over the place and then we have
frequently we get libertarian and
conservative guests but if they're going
to make false statement of statements of
fact about one of our co-hosts Sheamus
was a temporary co-host he's a coach on
the show for quite quite a bit but he's
not a staff member here he's just a
recurring guest and friend of ours he's
not a part of the he's not he's not like
a core staffer at the company so I'm I'm
sorry like this this might end up being
very very expensive we got we gotta look
at how many views they got how many
shares it got then we got to do
corrective marketing and they're going
to pay for it who super chatted that by
the way because thank you so much for
that that was uh tangent tangent they
pointed this out really a lot I don't
know I'm gonna try and play this because
maybe it's here this is going to give me
like
uh no I don't know if this is It's the
time step he gave us in the full episode
we don't have that we only have the clip
so it's gonna be hard to find yeah this
is the episode with Chloe Carmichael the
Ping trip famously took out of context
on purpose to make a killer uh satire
video oh it might be this let me let me
play you know it's funny because we live
in this culture where no fault divorce
is the law of the land and people will
say things like well look how often
marriage ends in divorce how could you
ever be in favor of social structures
which disincentivize that or would you
know dissuade people from getting
divorced but I think what people often
miss is if young folks know they're in
an environment where divorce is not an
option I firmly believe they're going to
be more careful about who they choose to
marry and I think also people to be more
careful about their decision making in
general when it comes to sexuality a lot
of people will start sleeping with
someone and as you've mentioned that
releases oxytocin and other hormones
that Bond you and there are a lot of
couples that end up together because
they're sexually engaging with one
another and they're bonding but they're
not actual really really good for each
other and then at some point in the
marriage when the novelty of that person
wears off they get divorced so I think
well there it is it was Sheamus Jezebel
posted fake news a false statement of
fact about who said what see here's the
thing Sheamus is a Catholic conservative
he is it's so he has those opinions not
Ian Crossland no definitely oh man
that's uh that that's that's bad for the
reputation of the show I'm gonna have to
uh man you know we have to employ some
corrective marketing here so you go
after obviously the company well I'm
wondering Kylie Chung the author or do
you the company Jezebel like who's on
the hook for that both of them yeah
they're both yeah so Jezebel's supposed
to have a standard here where I mean
this is a this is a Brazen fall
statement of fact they're not going to
be able to hide behind opinion on this
one they outright said Ian Crossland's
ads quote and not only that the quote
from Sheamus was very long he made a lot
of interesting points and uh it's it's
interesting that they cut out a core
element of what he said which is the
release of oxyto person the uh you know
that people are engaging in hookup
culture they cut all that out attributed
to Ian Crossland who's not a
conservative commentator and now they've
got a very very direct false statement
effect that's not an opinion statement
right they said Ian Crossland did this
thing you did not do it that's false oh
well
we're gonna have to I'm going to call my
lawyers after this you know I didn't
even catch that thank you to tangent for
pointing out it was Sheamus who said
that 965 million dollars right now
or else I'm paying his legal fees yeah
965 million the reality is not too much
that's not too much let's do something
about it because you are in a position
to do something a lot of the little guys
out there that have these kinds of
things happen to them in these media
organizations all the time they don't
really have the ability to fight back
you know it felt very like I was being
molested when I read that the comment
that I didn't make attributed to me I
was like this is like a really creepy
feeling but I had the confidence knowing
I was coming on the show tonight to talk
about it if I didn't have a show like
this that would have been devastating
because I I even started to question did
I say it yeah what's wrong with you have
no way to fight back
so here's here's what'll likely happen
um corrective marketing is Damages and
in all seriousness I'm gonna have to
talk with you know our marketing people
and a lawyer about it to see how we deal
with this because you know I'm uh it's
out it's out there people are talking
about it yeah um I tweeted about it
calling it absurd and laughable and so
we'll take a look at it but the reality
of what likely will happen is they will
issue a correction and that ends it up
if we have to do corrective marketing we
can then escalate and say no no you got
to pay damages because we got to pay for
marketing because of what you said if
they're going to correct it at least say
that I'm a wild hippie right if you're
gonna if you're gonna categorize me as
something geez it depends EMT in the
corrections you know it depends on how
many hits it got we'll have to we'll
have to the corrective marketing will
involve Research into the reach that
this did so there's probably a bunch of
YouTubers who talked about it and then
started repeating the lie that Ian
Crossland said these things he never
said so hey man it's one thing if they
said in our opinion in Crossland you
know as a fascist or a conservative you
can't sue over that's in a protected
opinion but this is an outright false
statement of fact that's like very very
obvious so it's it's Reckless disregard
for the truth in that capacity that's
that was Shameless we'll see let's jump
to the next story though the next story
is a video that I can't play because uh
Ethan Klein said something that I'm
surprised he didn't get banned over
which I'm not going to be able to play
but I can basically tell you what he
said
left-wing YouTube Star Ethan Klein Muse
is about another Holocaust against the
Jews and says he hopes Ben Shapiro is
killed first
yeah it's crazy what show is this on
it's his show H3 TV and they cut the
feed well that's his producers because
he's done stuff like this before where
he's gotten suspended and banned for it
strikes yeah so uh I'll uh without
playing what he says to verbatim because
look I think we'd get a strike for if I
think if we played with Ethan Klein said
YouTube would strike us right you
probably play up right to the point
where they cut right there but look I
can do this I can move it forward he
starts saying it his own producer then
yeah technical difficulties please stand
by because there was another point where
he called for an act of Terror on
Republicans like I'm not exaggerating he
literally said people should you know go
commit an active Terror and then he's
like okay it got a little carried away
there they bring it back and then
apparently after they bring it back he
just keeps talking he just says it again
he says it again yeah he clarifies yeah
so he was intimating that if there was
another Holocaust Ben should be he hopes
he said he hopes it's Ben now that's
something we were saying before the show
if him and Ben and a few other friends
they were all friends hanging out in
their room playing cards or whatever and
then he said it as a joke and they all
laughed about like Ben's the guy that
she get and there was like haha but you
go on TV when the guy's not even there
to defend him so that's a crazy thing to
say right yeah yeah and he's also called
for acts of Terror against
Republicans that's so weird is that
funny dude these people are dangerous
and insane seriously I like I'm I'm well
past caring about their opinions it's
been years there are so many people who
try to play this middle of the road
thing where they're like well you know
let's hear what they have to say I'm
like dude called for a terror attack on
a on a convention he's now saying he
hopes Ben gets gassed first these people
are nuts and this is I don't know if
he's going to get banned over this he
won't I doubt it well he did get a
strike from the from the terror attack
one yeah I mean that one was a direct
call to violence this I guess would be a
little more indirect
I don't think he should get a strike my
point on this is basically just that the
rules are in place because of people
like him and other leftists So based on
what they expect they should they should
get a strike based on their own
principles and own rules but you know
they don't have this their morality is
whoever can have the most whoever can
accrue the most power it's fascistic the
late David Graber said that an element
to the left has adopted the fascistic
tenant of tenant of there is no truth
but power and that's clearly on display
with people like him when he got a
strike for calling for an act of Terror
he acted like he was outraged oh hello
are you kidding dude even I think that
should have been a strike you know I'm
all about Free Speech but if you tell
your audience to go and do murders yeah
I think they should at least at the very
least be like hey we're taking that
episode down you shouldn't do that um
well there you go this is modern
politics for you where does this where
does where does this where does where
does this standard bring us I err on the
side of free speech for sure and I don't
want the feds being like Oh we gotta we
gotta just cause now to go take this guy
and and unperson him I don't like that
stuff man I'd rather just work it out
with Ethan like he's stressed out he's
saying dumb dumb stuff on the internet
and I'd rather work it out than cause
more of it
with someone like that sorry I I can't
believe I'm saying I kind of agree with
you if people want to be ridiculous
sensationalistic bombastic and idiots I
think let them and and let people know
exactly where they stand but I think the
problem is is that you know he gets to
do this he gets to get get away with
this he gets to hang out with Susan
wojinski someone on the other political
Spectrum or someone questioning the
establishment sneezes the wrong way
automatically uh downranked in the
algorithm demonetized uh screwed over
shut down deleted and censored in many
instances for just expressing political
thought and ideas not calling for
violence not calling for anyone to be
thrown in the chambers and and and
there's there's an unfair balance here
which I think is the critique here that
is fair to make here but the end of the
day I stand with you let people say
whatever ridiculous crazy stuff that
they want and let's let's let us know
where people are really coming from this
is where he's coming from
um and it's important to know agree or
disagree so we the conversation should
happen I do agree and I think his
opinion is not a call to violence it's
an expression of a desire for genocide
um and The prominent individual to be
killed and so I think that's horrifying
I think what his point he's trying to
make is
I'd be willing to bet
because I'm going to give him at least
as much the full context is something
like the right is anti-Semitic Kanye
West and that's why it comes up and then
he probably said yeah well you know what
if it happens it's because of them so I
hope that's what I think the context
probably is I ultimately don't care it's
an insane thing to say I hope Ethan
Klein lives a long and healthy and happy
life I say that about people I don't
like all the time I say look you know I
don't like what they do but I wish them
the best I would have a happy healthy
life and we find a way to live together
peacefully here's the issue
no one is going to come after him he's
not going to get censored the rules
don't apply to him he's going to get
away with it his followers are going to
laugh and enjoy it you get people like
Hassan he's a socialist then he buys a
multi-million dollar property he
advocates for policies to destroy the
working class and and the middle class
and then he uses that wealth to buy
fanciful and and and grandiose things
they they are both part of a faction
that advocate for sensors but people
they don't like and they get away with
it now in the end even if they come out
like we're being edgy you're making
jokes and we agree they should be
allowed to the problem is these people
would laugh when you got banned and we
here today are defending their right to
free speech and they do as someone who
has dealt with a lot of censorship and
banned from companies
um I'm well aware that yes this it
pleases the other side when they see it
and again we get banned for sneezing or
the reality is we get banned for things
and they refuse to tell you what you did
right because they don't want to put
that in writing that happened to us
recently I want to point out the company
people are mentioning this too no Ethan
Klein is Jewish right yes yes yeah yeah
him saying this I that's I understand
the point he's trying to make but it's
just like such a disgusting and violent
insane thing to say I'm just crazy you
know like you know more look I think he
and all the other uh uh Psychopaths
should be allowed to express this so we
know who the crazy people are my point
here is just the double standard we
would have when I was administrating at
mines we would have these weird
situations every once in a while come up
where like someone and it didn't happen
much and it didn't happen to a point
where I I felt really bad about it but
like a really popular person on the
website would do something that violated
the terms of service or that I thought
was like whoa this is coming close and
I'm like what do I do do I ban our cash
cow because the reason mine's is solvent
right now is because we have a lot of
views the reason we have a lot of views
is because of our popular video makers
do I ban the one the biggest Cash Cow
and it's like if I don't then I'm
letting fascism take over I'm like the
money and the corporation take my morals
and ethics away
um and if I do then the company goes
under what is what are my my two choices
here yeah that's a weird position to be
in as an administrator when I said
people were censored for sneezing the
wrong way I wasn't kidding as you were
mentioning Seth people people got
censored people got banned people got
their whole livelihoods deleted because
of vague terms and services that were
just there and then people were like
wait what exactly did you did you
destroy my livelihood for no we're not
going to tell you we just have these
vague roles with these over
generalizations and we're gonna punish
you because you expressed political
thoughts that we don't like and and it's
not like they even give you any kind of
ability to redeem yourself it's not like
they give you any kind of ability to to
fix your problem no but but we have this
on the other spectrum and again I used
to watch Ethan Klein many years ago he
was interesting he was creative he
actually did content that was engaging
and I don't know what happened to the
guy but it's it's sad to kind of see
this because this could also be an
attempt to try to get attention to try
to say say something shocking so more
people pay attention to you we are
talking about him right now but I think
he has strayed off a long way from where
he was before where he actually uh was
enjoying this he definitely doesn't look
like he's enjoying this he you know I I
wish the guy luck I wish he could you
know get in shape
I'll tell you I'll tell you what it is I
think it's simple it's not it's not good
watching this politics is pop culture
for somebody like me my whole life has
been politics when I was a little kid
um you know I work with my family's
business it was on North Halsted it was
Boys Town in Chicago so all of a sudden
I'm hearing all about these issues with
LGBT pride and stuff like that I start
listening to punk music all the lyrics
are about war and politics and all of a
sudden I'm on the internet I've been in
the internet my whole life I'm a little
kid and I'm seeing all of this news just
inundated with it I work for non-profits
I do fundraising it's all activism I
eventually start covering protests on
the ground my whole life is politics
that leads us to where we are right now
talking about issues that I've talked
about my entire life having me be able
to be able to remember weird things from
back in the early 2000s when most people
weren't paying attention to politics at
all Ethan Klein was a comedy edgy
YouTuber yeah and then at some point pop
culture turned into politics which was
huge for us all of a sudden me I just
talk about politics all the time
getting a bunch more viewers rivaling
some of the biggest entertainment
podcasts even Joe Rogan is now a largely
political show even though he's a
comedian Ethan Klein needs to adapt he
needs to start adopting politics
otherwise he's becoming stale and not
current right the news Trump Trump trump
that's all it was so it happened to
everyone it's not just him now he has on
Jordan Peterson on his Jordan Peterson
on his show yeah what happens for the
most part it's fine but over time he
starts feeling the heat because his fan
base was mixed politically because it
was edgy comedy and now his time's
changing a large portion of his of his
base probably skewing younger they start
getting angrier and more self-righteous
so he deletes the Jordan Peterson
episodes he apologizes that it was wrong
makes no sense yeah and now he's like if
I'm going to be relevant we have to talk
politics and thus Ethan Klein who knows
almost nothing about politics is having
a conversation with Ben Shapiro who has
been a political commentator for decades
and has a law degree
there's clearly a problem here with
politics becoming pop culture someone
who has no idea what's going on saying
they hope someone who is overtly
political gets killed first in a new
Holocaust is just absolutely insane but
he's entitled to his opinion he's
entitled to try and make his show
political and it's clear that he just
went meh modern leftists woke whatever
it's the easy route when you don't
really know what's going on it's simple
you believe jussie Smollett which most
of these left us do you believe Ukraine
gate you believe Russia gate you believe
Trayvon the hands up don't shoot you
Covington Catholic I love make saying
the list over and over again Bobo
Wallace the garage Paul wrote they love
believing this stuff because they are
low information individuals but they're
also extremely dangerous violent and
angry people they want you to just just
fit in the crowd is doing it why won't
you everyone is saying this is the truth
why won't you well because there is a
truth I don't care what you think it is
two plus two equals four not five shut
up I kind of will double down that I
think there's there's a saying with
great power comes great responsibility
and with 10 million followers that's a
sense that's a form of great power and
so the things you would say with your
friends in your bedroom or in your
living room when you're playing you know
Super Nintendo or whatever the hell uh
insults dirty jokes you don't say that
to 10 million people on TV because you
have a greater responsibility not to be
derogatory I know you want to because
it's natural it's who you were in the
past Ethan particularly probably like me
would joke you know insult your friends
as comedy but like this is taken on
another level brother
I don't like to talk about other
commenters you know we I mentioned this
from time to time like The Young Turks
talks about me all the time but they'll
talk about me saying something like
banal like you know I think some women
might be unhappy because they want to
have families and then they make this
big segment about temples of sexist then
I'm like oh come on dude calm down I was
reading the Washington Post this is a
high profile podcast which gets tens of
millions of views saying I hope Ben I
don't even want to read it I mean it's
just like come on dude that's crazy
there's also kind of the Britney Spears
effect when it comes to online
influencers and a lot of celebrities who
take themselves too seriously I'm not
saying that that's what's happening with
Ethan Klein but there is uh you know a
lot of people who are in the digital
space who are influenced by the Bots by
the comments and by the people a part of
this and you do see detrimental mental
health effects to this is this maybe
potentially one of the examples here I
don't know but but this is Art unhinged
very emotionally kind of very emotional
language that I don't think the average
person is going to believe me with yeah
gentlemen crack your beers now because
I'm gonna say it Civil War this is the
kind of stuff that I talk about this
this is I mean look when Security
Experts say we fear it's coming
when uh Princeton professors former CIA
when they're all like we think we're in
the beginning stages of a Civil War and
then a guy who used to make comedy
videos where he would push out his fupa
and pull his chin down and then run
around his house as a gag is now saying
that he he hopes Ben Shapiro is guest
I'm just like
yep listen do you see the radicalization
over the past 10 years do you see why I
might think writing that place Ethan
Klein for no reason there is no reason
why he an edgy YouTube comedy YouTuber
should be saying anything about Ben
Shapiro or holocausts or politics but
this is what's happened with the
radicalization in this country that's
why I'm like
that's why I think we're going to we're
heading towards the Civil War or we're
in a cold Civil War whatever you want to
call it when comedy edgy boys turn into
advocates for and like let me just
stress they tried stopping him and then
he was like no no then he said it anyway
yeah like when you get to that point
maybe everything's about to break apart
well I it's I agree that it's like a
radical a form of radicalization what's
happening is the society is very
stressful for a lot of people right now
with inflation with Ukraine with all
this crazy stuff going on if you don't
know the specifics if you don't
understand that Hunter Biden was
involved with barisma for instance that
Biden's had gonna you might just look at
it and be freaking out and then lashing
out which is what Ethan's doing like
he's obviously stressed about Society
like we are but we study the intricate
details about geopolitics so it's I'm
not getting radicalized like if I didn't
understand what was going on I'd be
freaking out screaming at people lashing
out and um I think if he I wanna I wanna
I want you to be more educated he may be
less radical his fupa work great work I
wanna I wanna try jump to this story and
I want to highlight uh something
specific but the story from NPR
ukrainians keep a weary eye on U.S
midterm elections fearing a loss of
support and I say good because I watched
uh something on Reddit I didn't want to
watch it I was scrolling Reddit all and
within one or two pages I came across a
video and I didn't read the caption I
just saw the video and it was a guy in
military gear curled up in the fetal
position in a foxhole
and then I'm like what's what is this
and then all of a sudden a grenade just
falls from the overhead view oh it was a
drone carrying a grenade the grenade
lands in the hole and then you see it go
off and the body gets shocked and then
this Soldier start writhing and crawling
and struggling to move like an ant under
a magnifying glass and then the video
jumps again this time there's three
people in a foxhole and then you see a
grenade fall right down land right next
to someone's side and then boom Flash
the body's jostle
then you see a man get up writhing in
agony and covered in blood shaking
profusely and I got really angry and I
really want to just throw my phone at
the wall why did Reddit put that in
front of my face am I supposed to
celebrate that the evil Russian Invaders
were being blown up in front of me that
when I go to a social media website with
no not safer work tags that's what you
want me to watch
people who are advocating for the US to
be involved in this are psychopaths I
don't like Russia for invading and I'm
not going to cheer for someone being
blown up but this is what we're seeing
so if the midterms mean we cut ties and
we end support for a war we shouldn't be
involved in at this point
good
I'm sick of this disgusting garbage it's
these stupid people on the left blindly
marching behind War yeah I just watched
they shall not grow old last night it's
a Peter Jackson documentary basically we
took Old World War One footage black and
white footage and colorized it and added
sound and you see these young 18 17 16
year olds that signed up for the war are
so excited the Brotherhood being
together working for a common purpose
and then they get to the that you see a
watch march to the [ __ ] trench and
then they're in the trenches where
people it's mud they're falling they're
freezing their feet are getting Frozen
off then they tell them to go up over
the top and charge the machine gun nests
they it's the first time they've ever
seen machine guns they don't even know
what they are so they start walking
they're not even running they're walking
but there's no machine guns they're like
what's going on maybe they're Germans
aren't ready the Germans are waiting for
them to get into range and then they
open up and they see their friends the
British these they're getting arms blown
off legs getting blown off dudes getting
their heads exploded and they're laying
they get hit they keep this is the this
isn't they didn't know Modern War they
didn't understand modern military
technology now foxholes are no good
anymore because drones can drop a
grenade in them this is this is always
War they they never underestimate the
new tactics and strategies sorry you
were gonna say no so one of my my first
job when I was 15 years old working at a
hardware store there was an old guy that
worked there and come to find out he was
on Iwo Jima and he never spoke about his
War experiences or anything like that
people would ask him stuff and he'd
essentially blow it off and he'd be gone
and I will never I was 15 years old so
it's been a long time now and for some
reason just one day he opened up and he
just he described landing on the beach
and running over the body's parts and it
wasn't bodies it was body parts of his
friends and it's like he he just like
clicked and it's this moment it was like
for a minute or two he just described it
and he kept talking about the smell
and it was just incred to see someone
say that and relive that in his mind his
name was Jack walking it's a true
American hero but to hear that from him
like it's left an impact on me to this
day it's been a long time the smell the
smell of explosion no well not at first
you don't smell it but then they start
to Decay and they yeah they were there
for quite a few days or weeks or yeah
the smell it's also an energy there's
also a lot of other things happening
when when it comes to human beings and
the Soul leaving the physical body
scientists haven't been able to explain
it but there's a phenomenon that does
happen that is absolutely
um I I you know Indescribable in many
instances but we also have to understand
war is hell this is Hell on Earth this
is what a lot of people you know are in
this is what the mainstream media is
cheering for this is what politicians
are financing and funding with your
money right now and it's absolutely
egregious and it's absolutely stupid I
watch you know a lot of the footage
coming from the Russians coming from the
ukrainians to try to get a fair balanced
perspective about what's really going on
uh in this conflict and it's
predominantly drawn on drone Warfare
drones blowing up drones drones flying
With Grenades drones reconing getting
positions and then having of course
missiles strike those specific positions
where soldiers are at and very few
instances have I've seen soldiers to
soldiers actually fight each other it's
all done through robots it's all done
through machines
um and and seeing this new Modern
Warfare which was which we were
conditioned to through the video games
which also have you flying drones and
flying all these carts and sending in
air strikes uh is is absolutely
terrifying because you see the horror
you see the chaos and it's not up close
it's not face to face like it was in
World War one it's far away and people
are just pressing imagine killing and
eliminating each other imagine that
you're uh 20 years old
and hey gen Z I want you to Imagine This
and your government calls you to war
they say we have no choice we are at war
with a great enemy and you must go fight
so you resist
and then one day when you're sneaking
out of your friend's basement because
you don't want to fight
a couple of uh cops see you chase you
down grab you and you get shipped off to
the front line you're at the front line
in Ukraine put the helmet on put on the
gear you have no time for training This
Is War
so you're pushed out into a middle of a
field and you're hiding in a hole crying
saying why am I here when a grenade
lands on you and blows up
that's what's happening to these people
many of these people fighting for Russia
are conscripts I'm not saying what
Russia is doing is good obviously I'm
saying it's bad
but to watch videos of these people and
then we're supposed to cheer on this
psychotic propaganda how about this the
U.S should not be involved in this NATO
should not be involved in this NATO
should take care of itself Ukraine is
not a NATO member not an EU member state
they're trying to be but only after the
war started and we should say you know
what we shouldn't be involved in a
border dispute with a nuclear-armed
state and then we wouldn't have to deal
with this psycho The Psychotic garbage
yeah you know and and again what we're
seeing though that Drone footage is just
one of of dozens of videos that come
come out every single day and it's not
just the Russians being hit it's also
the ukrainians being hit it's also
Russians sending in missiles into
civilian areas hitting buildings where
people are just trying to live their
lives this war hits both ways and this
is the this is how all war plays out
every time there's a war both sides
figure something out hey they did this
thing technology advances tactics I'm
sorry technology advances tactics
advance and then when the new war breaks
out like Ian was mentioning they're in
the trenches saying charge and also
sudden there's machine guns mowing them
down because tactics change slower than
the technology technology changes so I
actually have a civil war bullet it's a
gardener bullet I think it's 58 caliber
and uh it's a fascinating I gotta I
gotta the the the
um Stonewall Museum
and uh it's got some interesting facts
on it it said that for the most part
muskets were smoothbore very inaccurate
effective only up to about a hundred
yards I believe it was 100 yards
smoothbore so you'd point it in Fire and
it'd go wildly in the wrong direction at
some point uh up right before some point
before the Civil War we get rifle rifled
muskets so now for those who don't know
rifling and the reason why they're
called rifles is because the inside of
the barrel has a small spiral Groove so
when the bullet is fired it spins
dramatically increasing accuracy
tripling or quadrupling the range of
your standard musket when the Civil War
broke out neither side truly understood
what that meant and used conventional
War tactics like bayonet charges and
then with a maximized accuracy we saw
one of the bloodiest Wars we've ever
seen this is what happens when new war
breaks out with technological
advancement now that we have a massive
global population and technology is
advancing quite dramatically it's not
going to be nuclear war you should be
fearing it should be the top secret
classified Weaponry they haven't told
you about which is going to be even more
nightmarish it'll be hacked drones uh
flown over civilian targets like your
family if that's what you're uh what
modern warfare Call of Duty doesn't show
you is the Drone getting hacked and
getting flown over Los Angeles yeah you
could hack drones in Modern Warfare yeah
there's also hives like small little
drones that are also in developed
already that could launch attacks on
individuals and and have little
explosives on them and have bullets on
them the technology that they have right
now is absolutely insane and and we
don't know much about bro listen
the a small a small drone probably about
this big can carry a Shotgun shell a 12
gauge or whatever and it can be
um with a what's it called Luca flash it
flat
is that what it called it not a slug uh
spread razor blades oh sharp pieces of
metal I think those are flushettes
flechette and so that little tiny drone
can fly up to you and you go what's that
and then it bang and sprays metal shards
all over the place blinding and and
scarring people yeah amazing oh it's
just insane the level technology
it's not going to be fun but I'll tell
you man one thing they don't show you in
Call of Duty is the 20 year old crying
because he was conscripted by his
government to fight in a war and he
doesn't want to be there and then well
then his officer is like if you turn
around I'm going to shoot you go go over
the edge yep literally uh and they also
don't show you your friends getting
wounded and screaming and pain for 20
minutes or for four hours you know
because he can't get to them there's
going to be a handful of Jen's ears
because they lean very heavily Democrat
there's going to be two let me tell you
a story of two gens let's say let's say
they're 22 years old
one's a staunch Democrat who loves
watching H3 and agrees with Ethan Klein
about Ben Shapiro and all that other
nonsense watches Hassan [ __ ] and so
he's like you know what we got to stop
Russia we gotta we gotta stop him so
they say I'm gonna vote Democrat now
that the Republicans are that much
better but at the very least with Trump
he opposes this stuff
well that person has a friend the friend
doesn't know doesn't care and doesn't
pay attention but lo and behold the war
escalates NATO gets involved and the U.S
says we have not been able to replenish
our forces to to a degree where we could
actually fight and win so we're going to
reenact the draft
these 22 year olds let's say it's in a
few years so they're 18 today they both
find themselves on the front lines and
one is saying why is the the the one
friend friend B who uh doesn't never
paid attention to this doesn't care is
saying I wish I paid attention and could
have done something about this and the
other friend says well actually I kind
of voted for it and then the bomb goes
off and they both explode you know I was
thinking where are our strong men
sociologically in the world right now
what happened why are people so latching
onto Donald Trump and Jordan Peterson
why do they need a father figure if you
know what put it put attack in that well
it's because they were sent to
Afghanistan in 2005 they had their lives
destroyed it's a good point but put a
pin in that yeah I want to watch I want
to launch the news story which which
leads into what you're saying from
timcast.com new report finds U.S
military is weak unable to win a single
major regional conflict analysis
identified profound lack of seriousness
as a contributing factor to the US
military's decline Ian you were just
talking about a lack of strong men yeah
I was wondering where they are why
Society is obsessed with people like
Donald Trump and Jordan Peterson these
these men that are giving young children
guidance like the the heroes of our
lives and it's because they were sent to
Afghanistan and Iraq on a false premise
that Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass
destruction which he didn't have they
were lied went to fight an unjust War
had their psychology destroyed knowing
that they were fighting some false
narrative and then their bodies blown
apart their friends destroyed and now
they're now now they're shaken and our
leaders are absent they are the one
they're supposed to be leading the
nation right now and instead we got
fauci I wrote
Joe 86 year old president how old is
this guy now 84 years old and he's
supposed to be our military commander
I think when you talk about where did
the strong men go and I understand your
point there too but something else that
I like to harp on a little bit is it's
you know testosterone if you look at
what's happened to male testosterone
over the years it's nearly half of what
it was 50 years ago so men today are not
the same men of 50 years ago and so I
think that that might explain a little
bit about where we're at and I think
that people until people start realizing
and addressing that it's not going to
change most 20 year olds have the same
testosterone levels as 50 and 60 year
olds
pfas huh pfas phthalates
glass glass bottle water I wrote about
Marco Rubio small water our soldiers are
some of the most badass humans on Earth
those dudes every time I meet a
returning I don't know if did you serve
in the military but every time I have an
opportunity to talk to someone that's
actually seen combat or experience that
is like is like and it's like it's so
valuable to the human consciousness to
understand what that is and those people
to put their lives on the line like that
um but to have gone through a false War
I mean I don't know if would you call
that a false flag if the government says
he has weapons of mass destruction you
go in he doesn't yeah they said it was
they had bad info George Bush Jr is like
we had bad intelligence well you know
what it's on you George they didn't even
go through a false fight they just
claimed it was and then it wasn't it was
like it was like the next level of false
Flags there was no there was people
within the government that came out and
said hey there's no wmds here they were
silenced there they were shunned they
were threatened there was media
organizations there was there was
activists coming forward hey hey this is
not true this is not happening Sean
decided they should have just come out
he's been like ladies and gentlemen
Saddam Hussein is trying to trade oil in
Euro
and then people would be like huh we
need you to mobilize like Stormtroopers
and invade and Conquer their land
imagine how no one would have done it
people would have would have revolved it
they would have said no we're not
Invaders dude uh you say that but I
don't know that they would Revolt I
think what you're saying is maybe the
right thing but I don't know that the
people would have revolted uh they would
have worn the mask and done as they're
told like most Republicans did and quote
unquote conservatives did and shut down
their country and done whatever the hell
the government told them people are
sheep but that's with an excuse like if
we told people the truth about Iraq then
they would not you could have kind of
had the truth on the pandemic early on I
guess my point is more a lot of the
people that even speak out and claim
they're conservative this that and the
other the vast majority of people are
following this is because the pandemic
rolls around in our male adult leaders
are broken from their service in the
military like this those are the guys
that are supposed to be in Congress
right now running the show these are the
leaders they're the ones that are the
brave ones I struggle with that if you
think that just because someone's in the
military makes them a great leader then
that means we've got Barracks full of
future presidents
I'm just saying so if you look at a lot
this yeah canceled on this I'm about to
say you got John McCain you got Dan
Crenshaw like if you do look they are in
unless you're maybe the true generals
and stuff like this they're kind of used
to following other orders from the
government and that doesn't always equal
the best Congressman I know I'm getting
canceled I'm sorry they make great
politicians you know that's a great
point the multinational corporations or
the big Bankers or their generals and
they're just they just follow the words
I don't want to I want to clarify I
don't think that being in the military
makes you a great leader but I think
that great leaders are drawn to military
command
uh
and when you find out that you've been
commanding a military on a false premise
kicking indoors in Fallujah and killing
families okay do you assume the same
with the police though
uh
no no I don't know much are there
different systems to me I think putting
your life going and and willing to fight
like and kill people for why are you
assuming that's what the military is
yeah see and you don't understand some
people are like I I want money all right
I want I want to be here
guys guys guys there's no one in this
room who's a veteran okay right not a
single person let's say the Holiday Inn
last night and the most I can say is
that I've spent a few months a couple
different times on military bases but
let me tell you a lot of it is just
administrative work so assuming that
someone joining the military army navy
whatever it is is fighting is wrong yeah
yeah but some people are in support of
the fighting it's one or the others yeah
but bro someone might be like a
refrigerator repairman in Nebraska
that's repairing refrigerators for the
troops in Afghanistan
no dude come on
yeah they're keeping the administration
a point I'm trying to make is for the
war machine when you say that if you
want to make a point about people who
have seen combat is different from the
military oh no I'm talking about command
command structure basically somebody who
repaired refrigerators in Nebraska is no
different than a private refrigerator
repairman I mean I guess great leaders
aren't drawn I'm not saying maybe your
refrigerator payment and you are a great
leader but usually great leaders are
drawn to military command like they want
to they want to protect and serve the
world I think maybe you're picturing
people of the past that maybe the World
War II uh Era military veterans which a
lot of them did see combat if you were
in World War II and equating that to
what today is but I I just don't see it
today when a 22 year old is he gets a
commission and then outranks like a 45
year old NCO like those those are funny
scenarios that I've seen as just someone
as a family member at the uh at like the
what is it called the commissary is that
what they call them I don't know because
I I I just have family members and I'm
like buying food and I hear the
grumbling from the guy who's who's like
a non-commissioned officer being like
why is a 22 year old giving me the
business oh then he's got a bad
Commander a good 22 year old bro come on
a good 22 year old Commander will defer
to his NCO no yes no a good one will
because he doesn't always do he's great
they outrank him yeah but you still as
you're coming at the commander you defer
the guy with the experience in real life
right now the military is training guys
uh how to wear heels right this that's
literally unfortunately it's not
happening right now Shattered by the war
in Iraq okay I think I think maybe you
can put part of the blame on the war in
Iraq but I'm just you know there's I
think a lot of other factors that come
into play and I do think you know kind
of my point about the police versus the
military you don't have the same belief
in police that are willing to put their
their lives on the line Etc
I I think you make a hard time jumping
to just because it's military police is
different military command I'm talking
about commanders the commanding force of
our military is like some of the
greatest humans on Earth that's why
they're in charge of our military and we
need those people in civilian life doing
the same thing Consciousness are these
the same people that you earlier talking
about committing the atrocities of
sending drones over and killing people
and frivolous Wars ordered by George
Bush well then you're not available
to just believing that generals were
smart he put a lot of faith in the
military and he really believed that
they had to say and boy did they screw
him over well no and also you know
Ivanka came in and Jared came in and
they're like we want you to bomb Syria
Trump's like okay go bomb Syria and
that's what Trump did look that's
according to Trump's own son by the way
not just hearsay and look at what they
did when Trump was like you know what
I'm getting our troops out of Syria
because I made a promise to the American
people and they went oh you got it boss
don't do it and then they lied to us and
claimed they did when they didn't I was
watching video well I mentioned that uh
they shall not grow old and when you see
returning troops get treated like
garbage like it just shatters their
confidence and makes them unable to
function in society like it's for our
troops to come back from Iraq and
Afghanistan and be treated like they did
something wrong is the worst morale
destruction of our society I agree yes I
agree but exactly what he's saying you
look back to Vietnam the same thing and
I don't know that I don't think you
could say that men were destroyed from
being men after Vietnam yeah they were
that generation was annihilated they had
no confidence they would they were
completely used and abused
I understand that they were mistreated
someone when they got back but my I
guess my point is you're saying that
where did the men go and I guess so did
we lose men being men after Vietnam or
did it happen it happened after Iraq our
current Society this this flawed
narrative that we're we're struggling
with right now as a result of a lack of
male leadership this idea there's
toxicity I agree with that you guys want
to hear a funny factoid do you know why
Smith is the most common last name
Smith Schmidt and other forms of it
because whenever a war would break out
there was one group of people that would
never be sent to war and one group of
people that would never be executed when
a nation was conquered the people that
could make things the blacksmiths yes so
when a war broke out the blacksmiths The
Smiths would stay behind and make
weapons if an enemy Force took over that
country or land they would kill everyone
but the Smiths because they could use
them Smith kept having kids yep exactly
that's right because they were they were
valuable you needed someone to make the
weapons so my point there is the people
who didn't see the war typically were
the ones that propagated and you know I
think to your point Ian it's actually
more than you realize like Vietnam World
War II we had people come back from
World War II the greatest Generation
Vietnam was destructive I mean people
lost their minds and then you get Iraq
and Afghanistan and also it's just it's
it's Insanity at that point I mean World
War II I think for a lot of people
regardless of your politics there was
something really bad going on in this
world and and my understanding is the US
didn't know the Holocaust was happening
until after they got there later that's
true but that's contended uh there's
polish
contended contested they knew contended
let's figure this out
contending the contestants
listen I'll make all the words up I want
um and it's history so you think they
knew exactly my truth they absolutely
didn't know and they were given
intelligence especially from a Polish
government officials and there was a lot
of photos there was a lot of videos and
they had the opportunity to bomb the
railroads according to the history that
I particularly saw and decided not to
and there was uh you know a lot of
corruption within our government and a
lot of Nazis within our government like
Prescott Bush that of course openly
supported Hitler along with you know the
Rockefellers another very powerful
families they definitely knew about it
World War II was sort of a defensive War
uh because Hitler had taken France at
that point and the argument they will
try to make it look defensive that's the
whole thing we were attacked by Osama
Bin Laden we must create a war no that
wasn't a defensive war that was a war of
aggression and they used some cheap
pretext for it watch out for the next
one definition of Cambridge English
dictionary Tim contended is a real word
so when you I know it's a real word but
it doesn't make sense in the context in
which you applied it it's like rockets
on the board read the definition when
you put rockets on the border of Russia
and then Russia invades to take care of
those Rockets you can't call it a
defensive War because Russia is the one
that crossed the line you put the
Rockets right there on the other side
it's not a war of Defense right now it's
like it's just as aggro as Vietnam it's
nuts yeah would America allow those
weapons on the Mexican board hell no
hell no and like Russia needs black CS
access through Nova sabirisk if Canada
had our entire West Coast had just a
strip of land all down the West Coast
California we didn't have any Pacific
Coast access we would have invaded no to
take that pacific access
all right we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
Channel and share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
we're gonna have a members only show
coming up for you about 11 p.m they're
always good fun spicy and uncensored we
had a lot of news to talk about in the
members only show so you don't want to
miss it but let's read what you got to
say potatoes for Sheamus says Tim and
cast great job on the latest cast Castle
I do think it was one of the best some
people have commented they're not fans
but hey hold on look like I mentioned we
are not a major Hollywood production
house the people acting on cast Castle
are quite literally just the employees
who work here and we direct them and say
okay say this say this and they can't
always do it no beef you know we're
excited that we get to have fun and
screw around and make these episodes so
we made it as offensive as we could no
we did we could have been way more
offensive but it was and I think Rusty
Cage was absolutely brilliant if you
guys not familiar with him he's a big
YouTuber and he does really funny videos
and uh he came in and he was our sexual
harassment trainer for the company but
I'll just give you the gist of the
episode maybe I want to watch it the
mistake occurs when someone says we need
to have sexual harassment training and
instead of teaching people how not to do
it Rusty comes in and teaches them how
to do it yeah that's the joke and then a
bunch of other stuff happens that's
actually only the B plot anyway but it
was very funny he's great Rusty's
awesome yeah he was absolutely fantastic
yeah check him out all right pirate
Taurus second half says Netflix users I
canceled my account months ago they
continued to charge me two times a month
argued refunded only 15 bucks told to
complain to my bank
so the reporting now that Netflix has
has jumped 2.4 million users and they're
like hey they're rebounding and I'm like
no they aren't they're cracking down and
password sharing but I mean good for
them they're making more money but uh
yeah password sharing
Cody Justin Fannin says holy cow a
notification with this topic that's
right there you go hey there we go
finally the notifications are going out
huh some people
all right Christina H says did anyone
else have a hard time canceling their
PayPal account I had to argue with them
a bit before they finally did PayPal
canceled me so I didn't have to worry
about it what happened you were
mentioning a canceling what happened
exactly uh we've been canceled by
everybody it seems like uh we're not
allowed to order from Vistaprint uh
they've told us uh we are out of bounds
I guess they won't tell us why the
biggest thing that happened to us
recently was I'm going to name them
clavio who was our email provider
they're a billion dollar company I'd
been with them for approximately two and
a half years or last month with them I
spent I think about three grand with
them I get an email saying uh your
content meaning our email content
violates our you know it's hateful
content that goes that encourages
violence or some nonsense like this of
course I respond and say oh this is news
to me someone at the company must have
done it other than myself please shoot
me an example of where this hateful
content that promotes violence is and I
will get this handled immediately and
the response is we can no longer discuss
this matter you've got 30 days to get
your stuff and go well the thing is when
you have an email like this costs our
small company a lot of money and when
our main way of communicating with
customers is sending an email when we
have new products whatever it may be and
you lose yes I still can take my email
list but I've lost so much data I know
who wants to buy hoodies and who wants
to buy T-shirts or who prefers whatever
all that gets lost and then I have to
re-upload to a new email provider and
I'm no longer a trusted sender and we
had great incredible open rates for
email because people want to be on our
list so you're starting from scratch and
getting sent to spam and it's it could
put a lot of people out of business
that's why you get off got to get off
PayPal I'll tell you right now for those
that are listening a lot of people
stayed with so so we used to use PayPal
for our memberships because when we
start up the website it was the easiest
and fastest and it was cheap we had a
big burst of new users so we immediately
implemented stripe stripe has made much
better guarantees whenever we had a
problem early on I sent a message to the
CEO himself and he quickly addressed it
and apology and that's fantastic PayPal
does not do that so I like stripe
stripe's still far from perfect though
locals uses them it's just uh you know
locals of course was bought by Rumble
and then Rumble actually did one better
Dan bongino I think to some degree
Rumble invested I'm not sure launched
parallel economy so what we did was as
soon as we could it took some time we
got set up with parallel economy that's
Dan bongino's Financial transactions
company
got rid of PayPal from the website and
now all default signups all signups
default through parallel economy it's
Rumble Dan bongino because we are
building the parallel economy and it's
risky there's risks with new companies I
mean we could I mean who knows me the
company doesn't make it whatever but I
don't know it's more important many
users said I don't care I'll keep using
PayPal you don't have to stop using it
you can't sign up with it anymore a
bunch of people because of what happened
recently started switching off finally
so if you want to get off the uh PayPal
then the easiest thing to do is just
re-sign up with parallel economy and
cancel your account with PayPal or uh
email members at timcast.com and we will
try and help you set it up some people
were really awesome we it's not so easy
just to transfer the account over
because if you already paid like on the
first since the 19th we can't like we
can't issue Pro rates it's not that easy
to do but a lot of people are just like
considered an extra contribution and
we're going to help you out so I really
do appreciate it but for many people we
tried to find a way to do refunds I
don't know if we can actually do it
because when you sign up if we refund
you it like I think it might cancel the
account or something so I don't know
look all I know is we are trying to get
away from PayPal and we're doing the
best we can and I appreciate everybody
who did switch over and use this
parallel economy and I appreciate
everybody who reaches out to parallel
economy to support them in any way right
I look forward to parallel economy
launching little Terminals and then we
can open a coffee shop and we can use
them for everything it'll be fantastic
for the record what's the name of your
company that was censored via email
freedomspeaksup.com
all right we got Chas Charter and
morning morning says Ethan Klein has had
some really effed up stuff about Ben
recently quartering did a video about it
today
it's just so weird you know yeah it's
weird when people have no business in
politics all of a sudden become violent
that's crazy then
all right
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim today's
been an angry day after ammon's story
after our electeds not caring if their
actions so death after divisive Media
enlived or laughed or lied I was a fool
for for so long now I'm pissed yeah I've
been feeling that energy amen Bundy's
the member at member episode we did last
night with Ammon was crazy because there
was so much that I didn't know about his
story a lot of people think that like
you know him and his family like had an
armed standoff with with police nope
unarmed protesters it was a group of
them with no weapons peacefully standing
and protesting that was it but they were
in the vicinity of people that were
armed that hypothetically had pointed
their weapons although I don't know if
there was proof of that but anyway the
entire case was dismissed the charges
were dropped right and then uh the first
charge the first charge is an organ that
were they were got acquitted on and the
second charges in Nevada they proved
prosecutorial misconduct the government
was withholding evidence it's an insane
he was in solitary he was in prison for
eight months without searching him and
then when when he refused they lied to
the judge and claimed that he refused
transport to his own trial so the judge
calls him and then he's like your honor
I'd like to make a verbal motion to
mandate the prison transform me to my
trial and she's like wait what they said
you were rejecting that and he's like no
they're the ones doing it the whole
thing was corrupt they said they were
beating him why are those people not in
jail the ones that lied to the
courtesies bro yeah you'll need to be in
jail because it's illegal yeah
absolutely you you're committing a crime
against another human being at that
point that's being kept in a prison it's
it's incredible but those people will
continue to get away with yeah like like
withholding evidence I think I don't
know the legalities of it but no one's
going to prosecute them because they're
on the right side
sorry forlat says I can't wait for the
FBI to raid cast Castle
thinking about it I was like you know
that journalist who went missing should
I like commission a very expensive like
six-figure investigative piece and I'm
like the reality is it may turn out the
dude left his wife or something and quit
retired and went to the Bahamas you
don't know so I'm like no we shouldn't
do any stupid stunt but uh I imagine the
it's the journalistic work that would
result in something like that
because you know James O'Keefe we'll see
what happens
I'd ways says wanted to know the metrics
on the revamped cast Castle I know there
were some that complained about the
changes but hard numbers are good to
have I don't have any
um I don't know I don't uh the metrics
with YouTube are easy you can see them
but since we've shifted to the internal
metrics I actually don't know the
metrics on our internal stuff and I
don't really care I can tell you the
metrics are the metrics that matter are
people are signing up and watching it
and so we're making enough money to keep
doing it and that's what matters when
cast Castle was a daily Vlog on YouTube
it was losing lots and lots and lots of
money and we kept putting more and more
money into it
and it wasn't working and so I said okay
we can cancel it out right and just stop
making this stuff and there are some
people who are like fine and I was like
or we could make once a week longer
episodes do more skits that we want to
do and then make it a members thing and
see if we can get enough members to
because to sign up that will cover the
cost congratulations we have enough
people who have signed up that's covered
the costs that's all that really matters
if we can afford it we'll keep doing it
I don't want to just cancel it for
people who like it for people who don't
like it I don't know sorry some things
cost money I mean maybe it's you know
there there's uh let me tell you a story
Wendy's in the 2000s came out with
something called the Smoky cheeseburger
and they had this sauce the Smoky sauce
they called it and boy it was my
favorite burger and nobody else liked it
so they got rid of it if you can't
afford to make it you're not gonna make
it they're not gonna just keep it there
for me so that's just reality of
business yeah I thought a Arrested
Development was a really good show too
and then they canceled it but then they
brought it back because the internet
loved it
all right let's see CJ McLean says Tim
do you think a pro-choice the 20 weeks
Republican as president would help calm
the division in this country no
maybe it might benefit to a certain
degree okay but I think the problem is
as you as you saw with Ethan Klein thing
and Ben and being gas and all that stuff
these people it's not about policy it's
about tribal hatred and they're going to
keep saying this stuff until sooner or
later people go out and Riot and target
people you know Scott Adams was mocked
when he said Republicans will be hunted
then we saw a bunch of Republicans get
hunted not like every single one ever
but you know people were killed
there you go man
terrestrial G says Ian may be an oddball
but he's our Oddball check my music I
make Oddball music
well all right
moving on
Tim Jake says the First Amendment does
not protect journalists who disclose as
classified information read 18 U.S code
798.
uh I think it depends but uh you know
there's a Nuance Nuance in all things
DJ Madero says who would have thought
that Mel Gibson's conspiracy theory is
the dystopian future we live in which
conspiracy theory is that it's a movie
oh the movie oh that's what they're
referring to I thought I thought he had
like a specific conspiracy onto himself
oh the movie's awesome yeah the movies
like there's a scene where he puts a
bottle on his doorknob and so that way
if someone tries opening it like
jiggling it it falls over and it's crazy
yeah that movie is funny good stuff
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Abrams thinks
heartbeats are manufactured
you guys remember that
yeah another Georgia thing yep no what's
that
she said that the heartbeat you hear on
ultrasounds is a fake sound made by the
machine to so that men can control women
yeah that's the people coming from your
state that's uh that's a representation
where you're from it's unfortunate
coming from my country
Ivan ooh says only ever wanted has
radicalized Ian into Tim's right-wing
world
that's right that's a great song uh have
you laid down vocals on the new one yes
oh you did a while ago they were
arguably demo we might have to go back
and touch them up but they sounded so
good we'll see the one note we got back
for the new song was more harmonies and
then Ian keeps harping on harmonies so
yeah
all right straight white male says Matt
Walsh is holding his rally to end child
mutilation in Tennessee on Friday hoping
you have some journals on the ground
really
well if anyone's listening from our
Newsroom we should get on that
because we can that would be fantastic
that'd be cool Mountain rage collectible
says we sell sports cards TCG and Anime
so I'd like to hook you and Ian up with
some MTG products I'd also like to do
some kind of sponsorship or even help
with your brick and mortar yeah we're uh
getting we're setting up a a physical
location and we're going to be launching
the new show mall store
I had a conversation with uh some
individuals who are skilled in this
space and it's looking really good that
within the next year the show is
basically we got a storefront and we are
going to create a pop-up store once a
week that does something absurd I'm
going to give you an example of one of
the jokes that we that I came up with at
the top of my head and we probably will
do so I'm spoiling it a little bit but
I'm excited for this one it's going to
be a store called Pokemon IRL
and we're going to have people outside
yelling for families to bring their kids
to come in and watch Pokemon in real
life and the only thing inside the room
is going to be two cages on the left and
right with a rooster in each one
and then when the the parents come in to
ask what it is and get you know
noticeably offended by the idea we say
what do you think Pokemon is it's kids
training animals to fight each other so
that's an idea of like the jokes we do
the roosters will be in cages and side
note for those that don't know this The
Roosters will not actually fight
roosters only fight if there's girls
around when you hear about cockfights
those are specially bread roosters with
like they cut the Combs off and
everything and they make them really
aggressive he's talking about Georgia
again yeah regular over at cocktown
we've got like 18 roosters and they'll
just hang out and do rooster stuff as
long as there's no girls everybody gets
along so but that's one of the jokes
we're gonna do and then once a week on
the weekends we're going to no I think
Monday and Tuesday is when we set up the
new store and change it something
ridiculous
and then uh with uh throughout the week
with the weekend people can come in yeah
but uh let's let's uh grab some more
Super chats
all right let's see
ready to rumble says Ukraine has the
largest deposit of lithium on the planet
500 000 tons it all makes sense now wow
maybe you know people I was reading that
the Don bass region has a lot of lithium
with the loss of Afghanistan we're going
to need to get our lithium from
somewhere right maybe that's it huh
I think there was uh some super chats
earlier that were talking about Ian's uh
opinion about ncos and fresh uh fresh
commanders taking hints from their NCS
not it's really you know I was up there
earlier some of the super chats well
let's uh Kate Braden that's a lot of
stuff I saw from Vietnam a lot of good
great commanders that would come in off
the boat would be like you're the guy
you've been doing this for five years so
I'm following you for now right Daniel
Bennett says trucker here LSB Industries
out of Arkansas and Oklahoma produces
fertilizer and I've been watching their
stock price go up and up and up
interesting I'll take a look at that out
of all the stocks that I have the
graphene one has done has actually got
me a return everything's collapsing but
that graphene one when I was doing
calculations in 2018 I got that uh Peak
graphene will arrive in about 2029 is
when it's going to be globally uh
globally adopted things change obviously
that was a projection from like four
years ago but it's it's definitely I
think a smart thing to invest in Crooked
Smile says Mr pool what do you think of
using credit to acquire gold and then
later on using said gold for gold back
loans your thoughts also waiting on
financial advice videos please never
going to give Financial advice but wait
a minute are you saying that use a
credit card to buy gold then get a loan
with the gold and then what do you do do
you pay off the credit card and have
cash or something no that's margin stuff
be careful because if the gold goes down
in value then you're gonna owe all that
extra money you have to pay back your
your loan he's pretty much telling you
to make a gold Federal Reserve yeah so
so wait wait what is this you get a
credit card you buy gold with it now you
owe on the credit card then you use that
gold to get a loan all you're doing is
holding gold and having your credit back
I guess but then if the gold goes down
in value how do you pay the loan back I
don't know but what if a civil war or
world war three breaks out and everyone
forgets that's what I was thinking I was
like I'm buying a house and I'm like I'm
getting a mortgage if the collapse
happens I'm not gonna know I'm not gonna
owe anything
right
I don't know how that works well there's
no one to collect
Civil War happens it's just like all
right let's go yeah who's coming after
you who's got the Gatling guns I've read
crazy stories about people who got
mortgages and then after like a certain
like a couple like a decade or so with
like modernization and and documents
being moved they sent a request to the
banks to produce the documents proving
they had a mortgage and the banks
couldn't and then like the mortgage has
disappeared
yeah there was something I was reading
about
um it was it maybe may have been like a
scam or something but this guy was
pointing out that when it comes to debt
collection often there's so much
transfer of paperwork they don't
actually even have the original
documents anyway and you the first thing
you always do whenever someone tries to
collect a debt is request original
documentation
and many of these collecting agencies
can't produce it and if they can't they
you say bye have a nice day I don't know
who you are like for all you know
they're lying to you but then I was
reading stories about like when uh I was
reading about the um like Dillinger and
they said he would burn mortgage
paperwork at Banks so that they couldn't
ever try to recover the the property to
approve that there was a loan on it or
anything like that bank robber right he
would go in and just destroy destroy
debt paperwork that's crazy like a robin
because no but but it wasn't well some
argue it's because he was sticking it to
the Man others argue is that he was
trying to uh favor you know generate
favors with the oh his buddies favorite
with the public the public would be like
ah we like it when he does that stuff
because then all of a sudden they're
like we don't know how much you owe so
well too bad paperwork's gone
all right let's see
AO shooter says face it Tim the line has
moved and you are conservative now
because you seek truth you've become one
of us one of us one of us uh you forgot
to add Google gobble
Google gobble one of us I I guess like
in the modern era conservative means
that you want the truth
and you care about facts and the liberal
and left means you want sweet sweet lies
like rewriting history that would be the
liberal thing would be like we're going
to change what we don't like where's the
conservative things like just keep it
the same Paul renfer says so when's the
cast Castle episode of Ian bring bring
down on one knee with a ring asking Luke
to start a business for Loop to flex
muscles rejecting Ian because he is
married to his workout regiment
so well well-written idea
well there you go
moving on Jeffrey grajik says Ian come
to Texas and get married no alimony just
child support if children are involved
plus no state income tax
but it's also very hot and so is Florida
I like the heat I like West Virginia I
gotta look into those laws though West
Virginia's fantastic
Maryland probably is awful oh yeah
disgusting yep
it's getting cold right now stepped
outside last night it was frigid it's
not nice in the RV really are you
sleeping you sleep in the RV for now
CB says what they are trying to do is
paint the whole show as conservative so
the damage is all of timcast not just in
hmm
that's right the damage that's my new
nickname damage you know the damage here
let's call it Silo Simon Says Tim it
would be so fitting for you to have on
the YouTuber better Bachelor as a guest
he shouts you out on his channel around
400 000 subs and I found you there oh
that's really cool thank you better
Bachelor we'll uh we'll take a look at
that
take a look into that indeed
five against eight says easy calculation
Jezebel owes Ian 965 million dollars
well there you go that's so funny
Anthony Jones says Tim please show your
true Trek fandom put together a team and
go investigate the daily sightings of
uaps off our coastlines give the people
what we truly want that's a job for
Shane Cashman
we just talked about the uaps who was it
on Rogan yesterday he had a Navy pilot
we have that story pulled up we didn't
get to it yeah maybe maybe we can talk
about it after show I think we have a
couple of ideas to talk about but I
think a lot of what's happening is
they're focusing lasers into the sky on
distorting radar and causing like a like
a a morphing of the environment that
looks like a craft then they're moving
it around all weird they move it around
like what a craft might do to get the
pilots to think maybe it's an actual
craft setting people up for some sort of
false flag or whatever but they're
testing like Laser Technology called
talking plasma Carpe dantum hey what up
he says it's different when we do it
Democrats that's right and also we need
Elon Musk to get Twitter already so that
carvedantum can come back
mimic says it was nice seeing Sheamus on
the show again uh old memories Sheamus
it was four months ago he left emotional
times yep one day uh he told us he was
going out for scratchers and then he
never came back he must have won it was
he must have won one broke off of the
potatoes
he uh he got drunk off the potatoes and
then fell asleep in the gutter some nice
old woman picked him up and carried him
home and then he woke up in a far away
land and just he's got amnesia now keep
scratching Sheamus yeah yeah the uh the
videos on freedom tunes that are going
up it's actually me doing Sheamus's
voice doing other people's voices yeah
Sheamus you've been covering for him
that's right that's right because I'm a
good friend
that's right check out Freedom tunes on
YouTube if you guys haven't Seamus is uh
he's gone he abandoned us
all right Cindy drellick says regarding
Breaking Bad Walter White had some funny
gun scenes but as a whole did the show
get guns and ammo somewhat right glad
you finally saw the best TV series out
there Heisenberg
I like Better Call Saul better
except for the ending
everything in Better Call Saul was
really really good but the ending was
really really bad
it felt like there was no ending you
know I kind of don't want to spoil it I
haven't don't I haven't seen it and I
hear it's real good but well I didn't
like breaking down so the issue is when
you're doing a prequel and people want
an epilogue the epilogue is after
breaking bad but the resolution of the
prequel needed
they it so basically what happens is the
the show's end is an epilogue and I felt
like the prequel the series itself
probably should have had an explosive
climax
but I guess they didn't want to do that
because how do you because we know what
happens in Breaking Bad I don't know
yeah George Lucas did that with Star
Wars episode one as he wrote the prequel
second but he made it act he pretended
like you didn't already see the episode
four five and six and that you're gonna
watch him in sequence but everyone
already knew that Palpatine was the
emperor so it was like kind of right
flat
David T says happy to support a show
that's not afraid to bring on
conservative commentators like Ian
Crossland man he'd be a wild candidate
for president Tim is a brave man first
thing you do in office
uh I'm not going to tell you I'm not
going to say it out loud because it's a
big plan that it needs to be enacted all
at once I would immediately allocate 550
million dollars towards the production
of graphene
oh yeah full graphene Revolution we're
pulling carbon dioxide out of the air
we're doing video chats with foreign
diplomats and leaders all over the world
daily we're having at least one to three
hours a day on video uh live it's all
about communication if you're the
president your job is to communicate can
we just start firing people that's kind
of the direction I'd like to see I like
that I'm open to that just a bottle this
is a lot about us all of it yes
aggressively action man says I heard H3
is getting divorced wonder why I I think
that's fake I heard that I heard it
doesn't sound real and he was awesome
but yeah I I don't believe that but what
what is there something I didn't hear
about is it what was it well I heard it
and then I think Jeremy Hambly might
have said no it's not true yeah and then
that's the last I heard about it that
was like two weeks ago yeah it was like
oh no no uh Ethan said that Jeremy was
getting divorced and then Jeremy's like
he's no I'm not so that he said that
Ethan was getting divorced and then it
turned out they were both lying oh
just to get back at each other they
deserve each other yeah they should
marry each other have they done a show
together yet they should I don't know
yeah they definitely should
yeah
Captain tanker Joe says my grandpa's an
interesting man he claims to be fighting
socialism and authoritarians that he
votes Democrat he advocates for the
genocide of Russians openly I'm certain
if Stalin or Uncle H had a d next to
their name he would vote for them Uncle
h
yeah
not my name says anybody else feel like
abortion is similar to a deal with the
Devil with the baby being the human
sacrifice I can see that
you know in certain circumstances
especially post viability it's like I
want more comfort and wealth I know kill
this thing and give me what I want
oh what's this Matthew Dean Bodo says
did you see Kanye West apologize in the
Piers Morgan show a few hours ago I'm
definitely watching that interview later
that sounds cool
hostile bogey imbalances h3h3 was never
edgy it has always been cringe I guess
no the fupa and The Vape Nation stuff
was great and he had he had Jordan
Peterson on his show yeah but then like
he bent the knee got scared he did like
there are a bunch of YouTubers from back
in the day who were anti-woke they they
all panicked and just started taking
stuff down Chris Reagan took down Pancha
Nazi yeah apparently someone told him he
was helping Nazis so it was like then he
took it down it's like look man I think
there's some there's some there's some
good in that someone like Chris who
knows that his whole bit was like making
jokes and talking about games and movies
and comedy and hanging out with his
roommates was getting dragged into a
political conflict and also said like
why am I in this and a bunch of those
guys did said I don't want to be
political I don't want to be in this
world I get it even went the other way
he said I'm going to be fully political
even though I have no idea what's going
on I got this old video and I think it's
called pain I have a few old videos
where all I'm it's like I'm in the most
depressed hateful state of my life and
I'm talking about humans are horrible
they're dead they're dead to me they're
gonna die we're gonna wipe ourselves
it's like really negative and it's on
YouTube and I'm wondering should I
delete it or is it like part of the
story of what I went through
I don't know so you are because it's
like put it's still putting out that
energy and I don't agree with that
anymore I'll tell you what you can do
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
so you can watch the uncensored after
show we'll be having what we will have
tonight at about 11 p.m and the show
from yesterday with Ammon Bundy was
amazing plus the cast Castle Vlog is
silly offensive Shenanigans you don't
want to miss it you can follow the show
at timcastirl you can follow me at
timcast Seth do you want to shut
anything out uh yeah visit uh
freedomspeaksup.com you can find me on
most social media including Twitter for
now at Seth weathers for now I'll see
you there you never know yep our time
here is limited my YouTube channel is
youtube.com forward slash we are change
I did a story today about General
Armageddon yes that's a real legitimate
nickname on the new front in carouson
lots of very important updates check out
that video right now on youtube.com
forward slash we are change I'm Ian
Crossland follow me on YouTube subscribe
to me on mines get with me everywhere
you want Addie and cross on Seth we
didn't talk about physical health on the
the show I want to get into that we may
be on the after show we can talk about
phthalates and like what you've been
doing with your diet because like you've
got like a revolutionary Diet and uh I
don't know it's not revolutionary it's
very simple and basic but I think
everyone should eat way um eat steak
lift weights be unsensible and screw the
government that's all you need to do
love you thanks for coming man great to
be here and I'm serge.com and you guys
will see us in the Late Show thanks for
hanging out everybody we will see you
all over at timcast.com cheers